e
e e
a little after 10 we'll get started is
there anyone here to talk about House
Bill
187 no okay we'll talk on our own
then okay
okay good so let's look at it
restraining ORD sought by parents on
behalf of a minor child from the public
I just asked I don't see you
oh yeah
yeah I saw yeah especially if you know
what the bill does we would be very
[Laughter]
interested
okay so just tell us your name and
then and push the red button there you
go there uh my name is Tracy Sirles
okay um our family is the one that
brought forward to try and get this HB
going um yeah closer to the microphone
oh sorry um should I speak about what
happened and put us this far in well
just tell us first of all what what so
this bill is take Crossing off uh a
member of the Minor's family or
household uh or the words family or
household so it's making too little
changes yeah so what our family had come
into for an issue was something had
happened to one of my children and um
when we reported the crime the state
police told us to get a restraining
order so I went to the court to do that
and in doing so the judge said I'm sorry
I I can't do this for you my hands are
tied because of the way that the law is
written um currently only a parent or
guardian of a child um can get a
restraining or on behalf of their child
if the uh perpetrator was a member of
their household or related to them the
person who committed these crimes
against my child was not a family member
and not related to us in any way so
unfortunately I cannot get a restraining
order to keep my family safe so you
thinking about like a teacher or
something like that or is it uh no this
this was my child's best friend's father
gotcha um this has nothing to do with
teachers and stuff like that this is
just some other person yes and
unfortunately I can't protect my
children in this case because of the way
the law is written
okay um any
questions so uh the bill says
indeterminable increase of a small
amount of money and I assume that's
because there might be some more court
cases is that what we're talking about
here yes that's correct uh the judicial
branch wasn't didn't know how many um
additional court cases would come from
this so they just gave an estimated
range but it could be on the lower end
however there is no appropriation for
this so if this were to pass it
something they would just need to um
absorb into their budget yeah okay so um
what do you think should we should we is
this this doesn't look like the sort of
thing that should be part of house bill
to I mean just just pass the bill and we
done with it yeah no appropriation
doesn't impact the budget okay so would
someone like to move out to pass on the
I'll make a motion ought to pass okay
all right so we have a motion by um
representative C seconded by
representative rang that house bill 187
be recommended ought to pass any further
discussion no okay represent Ms um I
mean to me it it it just seems like it
makes sense I mean uh I I I guess the
only question I would have and I don't
think it's a deal breaker is why was the
limitation put there in the first place
yeah but presumably the children and
family law committee considered all that
kind of thing no I I think it's a it's
like a no-brainer yes right okay that's
why we're going so quick representative
Stringham I I was just going to ask what
what the history of the bill was as it
passed uh on um cons Melissa can
probably tell
us yep it was a Voice
vote thank okay all right we're ready to
vote okay all those in
favor all right looks unanimous
excellent thank you much have a great
thank you
okay I just I came for 66 I I I didn't
really have any just in case you had
questions for me yes okay great thank
you um should we skip ahead then
um
or okay why don't we why don't we skip
ahead I think that's all right right
Melissa yeah okay and let's go to House
Bill
66 um
no 66 there is a 566 but but next to
last is
66 and I have it right here so represent
Lyn did you want to talk about this
one I thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I I don't I I mean I think the
last time uh the committee discussed
this we had a pretty full discussion I I
don't really have anything to add I'm
just happy to if you have questions
about things um that's what I wanted to
be here to try to answer any questions
yeah why don't you remind us sort of as
to what's going on oh
um yeah what's going on with this fil so
what 66 um did was it
expanded um the um
the availability of people to be able to
get information under the right to no
law and it and it it did that in two
basic ways first it as you may recall
there were a couple of sections in the
right to no law not all of them but a
couple of sections that refer to the
term
citizen as opposed to the term person
which was used in most other places in
the rights of Noah
and uh that as
that had never been an issue as far as I
know and I I don't have I don't have I
don't recall ever having anybody say
anything to the contract that had never
been an issue in terms of being a
restriction on somebody being able to
get access to information covered by the
right to no law until a situation arose
in Rochester which I think we discussed
the last time of there's a there's a
there's a
a media uh person that covers Roch local
politics in Rochester and I forgot he
has a you know some kind of an an
electronic publication that covers
Rochester but he lives he personally
lives just across the border in Maine
and he tried to get some information oh
yeah and Rochester said nope you can't
get it because you're not a citizen
right so he went to court he he ended up
going to the superior court and there
was a long there was a very good
decision by judge will that basically
said no you're wrong
um citizen doesn't mean um what didn't
doesn't mean what you what what you the
town of Rochester or its Council said um
but anyway that raised the issue of you
know why does why is this why is this
term in there at all we we took it out
the other thing that it does is um it
allows um people that are that have a
New Hampshire connection they're either
a citizen of New Hampshire they do
business here they own property here
whatever they pay taxes here those
people are allowed to request
information
electronically and and if the town or
state or whatever whoever the
governmental body does is if they have
if they have the information in the
format that's requested they have to
provide it in that format um and that I
think that makes a lot of sense okay the
the last thing I would say is there the
reason we limited that the ability to
request and receive electronically to
citizens of New Hampshire is uh concern
by some and I I don't mean to I think
it's a legitimate concern that you know
if we didn't do that somebody you know
somebody sitting in their bedroom and
Beijing in the middle of the night might
say I'd love to know what uh what Epsom
has you know what the communications are
between the police and fire departments
and epsom send me all your emails and
we'd have to provide it and that
presumably would have a cost and you
know we didn't want to impose that cost
okay so I I remember two two things we
talked about here so on on page one line
26 member of the media there was some
people who said how can you fig you know
it's it's impossible to know that
somebody is a member of the media
because they could a blogger they could
be a whatever you know what there there
is a the there is a
definition of that not in not in this
bill because it doesn't Che but there's
a definition of that in uh the bill we P
the compromise Bill we passed last year
um and I don't I can't recite it off the
top of my head but there is a definition
of member of the media in that okay and
and is it something that um towns can
yeah I mean you know it does just so you
know it does it it doesn't mean you have
to be like you know the conquered
monitor or the union leader it it would
it would Encompass more informal but
they still have to be you know they
still have to have some some kind of
proof some kind of uh for lack of a
better term credential maybe credential
is a wrong word but some some legitimacy
and I forgot I wish I had the language
in front of me but I don't all right and
then the other point was on page two uh
line 17 we just we I didn't like the
fact that it says appeals shall have no
filing fee or search charge did we make
an amendment for that
Melissa no nope we didn't address it
okay that you know that again I I I
would say you know completely candidly
that's if you guys want to change that's
not a beach I would want to die on I
think we did that because as part of the
you know the uh the effort to make it as
easy as possible for someone who thought
they were being denied information we
thought that taking that out but you
know I as I say I understand the the
fiscal situation we have and if you guys
want to change it I'm not you're not
going to get any objection from me okay
so would people be okay with this bill
without that line well let's ask the
question it what's happening to do the
fiscal note again doesn't really affect
the budget is
that ta is correct but I also want to
make sure you guys have the correct
fiscal note does your top say as amended
as amended yes but it's all interminable
inter terminable indetermined yeah so so
representative Wilder is correct unless
you want to put some funding in here
this doesn't impact the budget uh the
right to no office would just absorb
these costs okay into their current
budget yes uh representative
Griffin um thank you for taking the
question um I I'm really a supporter of
uh the right to know and I don't think
it's appropriate fees for someone to get
information from the government it's one
thing to duplicate the cost if you have
to if you have to produce stuff but just
to have a fee to file I don't I don't
believe is right so the thank you for
the point but what we're talking about
here is an appeal to court from the
ombudsman's ruling so you've already
gone to the Ombudsman he made a he
looked at your case ruled against you
and now you say well the heck with the
Ombudsman I'm going to go to court right
so shouldn't we generally don't wave
court fees I would think I mean I guess
we do now in this particular case but um
yeah I I feel really strongly about the
right to know and I don't know whether
there's a requirement you go to the on
busman first us but no no you can I
think you can go either to the on busman
or to Supreme Court the only the only
thing and this this again it's not in
here it's in the bill we passed last
year I believe in the bill we passed
last year if you there's a provision
that says you know if you ask for
certain information the town can give
you an estimate of the cost and if you
challenge that then I think for that
only you do have to go to the udman
but uh you know to the udman first and
then the court for everything else it's
you can go to the udman or you can go to
court okay yeah so we we've already so
in the past people who were challenging
the right to no law had to go to court
right and when they went to court they
paid a fee right and so
um now we have yet another we have an
intermediate step that's much cheaper
right because the ombudsman's fee is
much less than the court fee um even
though we may be changing it but but the
point is you know already we're saving
you money right so compared to earlier
situation so anyways you can we can
propose it then you can vote against it
I guess um all right yes representa Ms
um thank you and thank you for coming in
and I I I think we may have talked about
this when you were in but I can't
remember if we talked about it uh before
or after you you testified but we heard
from a representative from the
Manchester Police Department that um um
providing records
electronically is a is a new requirement
and that that could add significantly to
the expense incurred by um uh local
local authorities particularly smaller
authorities that maybe don't have
scanning equipment and and all that all
that good stuff um can you clarify
whether if someone comes in and asks for
the records electronically that it has
to be provided electronically no it has
it it it has to be provided
electronically if they have the records
electronically but it doesn't require
scanning in other words if you if a if a
let's say a smaller Police Department
only has paper records and I I make a
request and say I want I want you to
send me this electronically the police
Department doesn't have to do they can
say no the only thing we have we only
have electronic record I mean we only
have paper records and if you want the
records you know we're going to copy
them for you but there's a charge for
for doing that so it doesn't it doesn't
require uh you creating electronic
records that don't otherwise exist um um
so thank you for clarifying that I'm
just wondering if that's clear in the
bill whether we need something that says
that specifically that cuz I don't see
that what what you described I think is
great but I don't see that in the in the
wording of the bill that says it um it
only has to be provided if the if the
records are available electronically you
know I thought it I don't I wish I don't
have the bill right I apologize I don't
have it right in front of me maybe I'm
missing it but um but but there may be
elsewhere in the right to know right
right let me um because we don't have
the whole you know
the whole
letter the reference to you know
providing the records electronically
that I see in here is on page it's on
the first page lines 29 through
um
person hang on one second
yeah um top of page two right right L
lines four five and six I think yes
right exactly no that's what I that's
what I'm saying I think it does I think
it does say they they only have to only
have to provide in the format they have
all right so I'm going to recommend an
amendment that just removes the sentence
on page two line 17 appeals shall have
no filing fee or sear charge and
otherwise ought to pass okay um we've
had a little discussion on it but
representative Campell yeah thank you Mr
chair um on this issue I tend to agree
with representative Griffin uh I when it
comes to right to know I'd rather air on
the side of the citizen than than with
the government and uh it's a small price
to pay to have transparency so um I
would I would be uh not uh in accordance
with that okay anybody else represented
wer I would support it especially since
we said to the court system you need to
raise your filing fees we need to get in
more money to support the court system
okay I would support your Amendment okay
anybody else okay so everybody know what
we we're going to just vote on having
this amendment um this will be uh again
page two line 7 remove the sentence that
starts with the word
appeals um all those in
favor
okay okay
against
against okay three okay so what do we
got is that six to three is that am i
counting right yeah okay good so now the
whole question would be um again I don't
think this is a house buil two type
thing right so we'll just do ought to
pass with Amendment
make sense I'll make that motion anybody
want to second second by repr so I'm I'm
making the motion on House Bill 66 off
to pass with amendment seconded by
representative Sweeney um any further
discussion no all in
favor okay one two three four five okay
and against three okay six to three very
good all right now were there any other
bills you wanted to talk talk about no
okay very good thank you representa for
coming in okay so we're done with
66 all right I also see chairman Aaron
in this audience maybe you'd like to
come
up are there are there particular bills
you're here for
[Music]
yeah both of you but but what about 215
this is something for representative eil
right
so we have some notes or
something
okay thank you representative Aaron
representing uh chair of environment and
agriculture committee representing svin
County District 4 uh the towns of aor
Goan langon hster and
Washington and
um so I know I I sent uh to Chairman
Wier uh a letter having to do with um
language that was in the trailer bill
hb2 for uh uh there was a solid waste
evaluation committee that was set up and
I had sent him some Communications
saying that um for that bill what we
wanted to do do is remove that language
and insert three other bills well we've
been in some discussion since then to
make some uh changes to that uh decision
or that
recommendation and um since uh HB 215
which is the
um uh what we call the lovingly the
harms and benefits
bill
um we were just in conversation with uh
Dees and the governor's office regarding
uh incorporating more of that language
into the trailer
Bill uh and so there's going to be some
amendment to that trailer Bill language
coming to you to the finance committee
um with that in mind but what I guess
we're here today is to discuss
hb25 alone or H how how do you proceed
with that if this is if this is going to
be part of house build 2 I think we
should retain house build 215 uh yes I
would we would be very much okay with
that okay absolutely and then and then
we can once you have all your ducks in a
row uh come back and talk about the
whole package right about the the uh
trailer Bill language yes unless but
because it sounds like you you don't
have it yet right so no we're we're
working on the changes to to the trailer
Bill language which will incorporate
more of hb25 into it so yeah so all so
how about we have a motion to retain
House Bill 215 representative Griffin
and seconded by representative run all
right okay any uh further discussion on
this one representative run thank you Mr
chair uh representative Arn and
representative gerana will the amendment
that you're going to bring to us for
hb2 I understand will incorporate some
of the elements of 215 what about the
other two bills so um the other bill was
HB 171 which is uh what we call the
moratorium Bill uh which is Seeking a
three-year moratorium on landfill
permits um and the the language in the
trailer bill is Seeking a one-year
moratorium I spoke with the governor
yesterday and she was okay with a
three-year moratorium and so that l
language is also going to be worked into
uh the trailer bill um
so HB 171 is not coming to your
committee I think that that's just off
to the senate senate land and well we
can make um House Bill two happen after
the effective date of that right so we
can make H House Bill two be the master
if if that's what you want right so sure
yeah yeah sure as long as that you know
the the moratorium langu you could put
all those things together in one right
big block right right yeah and the other
bill was U
hb77 which is a landfill sighting bill
which um I don't know
there's there's some consideration for
some landfill sighting in uh the trailer
Bill language as well
but not the entire thing and I know hb77
is not coming to your
committee
um so I don't know I think that that's
going to go separately to the
Senate and whatever elements of that is
going to be put in the trailer bill will
be there too okay but repres uh so but
we we're expecting from you it's just an
amendment regarding 215 and then we
would if we want to amend hb2 to a
dominate the threee moratorium no no
we're going to be giving you language or
we're working with Dees to give you
language to amend what's in the trailer
bill which will incorporate a bunch of
the other things so the other bills are
sort of separate except for 215 which
you are going to uh make a decision to
retain for us thank you yeah Melissa do
we have a sense of how the budget is
affected if we adopt the language from
215 versus what's already in the house
build too um that would be something I'm
asking Melissa oh okay I would just say
it seems like the biggest differences is
that with HB and you can correct me if
I'm wrong with h this 215 uh Dees is
requesting additional positions they're
not um 2115 doesn't authorize the
positions or fund the positions so if
you wanted to move forth with the 215
we'd want to probably put language in
there to authorize the positions and
fund those positions if that's the setup
your doing versus I believe hb2 is the
commission and I don't think you need
additional positions for that section so
that's a self-funded correct so that
that's the the biggest um Financial
change is an hb2 itself SF funded Dees
doesn't need positions 215 Dees is
responsible for and would need
additional positions in funding to
handle this new
element okay so yeah go ahead
thank you for the record uh Nick tra
chesher 15 uh yeah so when the committee
looked at the first version of of HB 215
the fiscal note was uh indeterminate uh
it was you know between zero and 100,000
but through the amendment process uh
apparently Dees then went back and
looked after we had amended the bill and
then this new fiscal note with the two
positions was added and that was another
reason why uh the chairwoman and I were
thinking would be appropriate to retain
the bill uh is because we want to try to
meld what we have in hp215 into the
trailer Bill uh but then hold 215 you
know just in case but that that fiscal
note was added after we we never saw it
when we heard the bill okay so we're
very reluctant to add positions and
spend more money so if what you give us
later does
that there's a risk it won't happen at
all so
well thank you very much Mr chair and
that's exactly one of the things that
were're we've been talking with Dees
about uh and thinking about the
governor's proposal and uh yes sir we
aware of those concerns and and want to
make them go away okay excellent all
right so we're about to vote on whether
to retain House Bill 2115 is there any
more
discussion no all those in
favor all right unanimous very good okay
thank you anything else you want to tell
us at this point but we're going to see
you again I guess is the um you I know
you had asked me in an email about
tipping fees is that something that you
wanted to have yeah that that's going to
be for when representative eel comes
back so but if you if you want to just
say something about the that concept you
asked for my opinion on that concept and
um that seems to be a a a uh um an okay
proposition okay
I see I see your colleague is likes it
too okay yeah thank you very much all
right thank you all right are there any
other bills the lee8 bill the lee8
management bill yeah 566 is also on your
okay 566 let's move to that
one okay that's the next one
here requiring permit applications for
new landfills to contain a detailed plan
for lee8 management all
right representative ger you want to
explain yes thank you Mr chair this is a
bill that uh I worked very closely with
Dees to craft the language for and uh
our committee did you know a lot of
great work sessions to to get it uh
where you see it here uh you know as
we're all aware we have had a number of
issues recently with leech a problems
particularly because of uh heavier rains
when we get you know two once in a
century floods within a couple of years
uh lee8 builds up in the in the layers
you know those liner layers within a
landfill that needs needs to be siphoned
off it needs to be transported it needs
to be treated uh before disposal uh and
the purpose of this bill is to require
anyone who is applying for landfill
permit to include with that application
a detailed plan for how they are going
to manage the lee8 uh onsite if they're
going to do any on-site treatment which
for example TurnKey does in Rochester uh
to to make it clear that they have re
they have contracts with more than one
uh party to dispose of the lee8 in a
safe and responsible way uh and so the
first part of the bill has to do with
the lee8 plan itself and then the last
few lines have to do with requiring the
reporting of contracts to to Dees so
right now uh companies have to report to
Dees that they have contracts this
language which again worked out with
Dees uh requires a little bit more
information about what is contained
within those contracts to make sure
again that uh safety is the the primary
concern with the transportation and
disposal of leech
a okay um so Melissa what's the
legislative history of this
bill this
one came out of um environment and
agriculture with to pass with
Amendment and it went to the floor and
passed on a Voice vote okay all right so
um anybody have any
discussion representative
Griffin I'd like to know um how did the
original committee vote on this we were
unanimous uh unanimous 13 to zero ought
to pass with
Amendment okay represent rung um Mr
chair may I U make a motion of OT that
we recommend otpa on this you have an
amendment oh no but it was amended at a
committee it's not going to be amended
out of this committee so just OTP okay
all right I'll second that all right so
moved by representative rung to
recommend House Bill
6566 ought to pass seconded by
representative camell
any further
discussion no seeing none all those
Melissa can I just pause for one second
can we just verify with Dees I don't
have an updated fiscal note for this
revised Bill I'm assuming it doesn't
change but I just wanted to bring that
up before you guys make idea is there
anybody here who can comment on that Mr
wiim fiscal note land yeah
thank you yes uh for the record Mike
whimet director of the waste division
for the dees um yeah that we have a a
working fiscal impact worksheet on that
that essentially uh establishes no
specific fiscal impact um Beyond um to
the extent that
uh trying to I've got a lot of them in
my head right now no I think this one
there would be no impact certainly it's
to State revenues or or uh or
expenditures right what the fiscal notes
says is that only if somebody submits
one of these applications then you have
to review it right so then there's some
cost right but our expectation is that
we would use existing staff to do that
in in fact that this bill what it
describes in in large part already
happens what is not explicit is that um
under the current law the uhu the
operator of a lfi is required to have
these particular agreements for
management of their leech a and to
produce them to de guess if we request
them what this law will change is that
those agreements the details of the
agree those agreements need to be
provided upfront with in the application
process so the the the we do not
anticipate any impacts to to yeah and
plus there's a there's a moratorium
right or we're thinking there will be
and
therefore there won't be any of these
applications and there you know anyway
well to yeah and it's a little Nuance to
the extent that expansions will still be
allowed depending on the circumstance
we even for an expansion you would need
the op would need to provide that
information very good any other no okay
all those in
favor okay very
good anything else from environment and
agricult yes yes
sir just for the record Adam kpo with
the Department of Environmental Services
I just wanted to comment on the back and
forth on 215 in in hb2 the amendment
that we're planning to bring forward
with the ENA committee won't have a
fiscal note for new positions it would
the duties that that 215 was planning to
charge the department with would be now
under this new SEC proposal and that SEC
is proposed to be self-funded through
filing fees and so there would not be a
uh fiscal impact to the department or
the general fund or any of that it would
just be uh the new filing fees as are in
currently hb2 so just wanted to note
that uh to assade those concerns so okay
we're very happy perfect thank anything
else any others that are related to Dees
on this
list are there other Dees bills on this
list Let's
see we got uh minor child Hampton
Hampton Beach no I think 624 624 624
local River Management advisory
committee grant
program maybe we should talk about that
yeah all right house bill 624
[Music]
you save
$10,000 I'm sorry 20 looks like 20 yeah
20 all right so is someone here
from Dees to talk about
this or someone else
no so just just looking at the bill um
and I just pulled up the fiscal note so
you know we would we would be able to um
adopt rules for this you know there's no
funding provided for de's administrative
costs and we're saying that uh it would
be a
$99,000 fiscal impact for FY 26 and a
$10,500 impact for FY
27 um we we would be able to abor absorb
those costs with existing staff so um
and what basically what the
program does is is give us um some
funding $40,000 for uh fiscal year 2027
and and the same for fiscal year 2026
and we would administer those grants to
local uh River Management advisory
committees but this is
um oh so this is a straightup
appropriation for a new grant program
right right we have some other things
like that in our
pile
so I think this probably needs to be
retained yeah system yes that because
we've retained all these other ones and
then we have to at the end of the day
maybe see if there's a few bucks in the
pile right for for those things
representative R thank you um Mr kbo
thank you for coming today um could you
describe some of the benefit these local
River advisory commissions provide the
state yeah sure so they they depending
on um you know which Association
you know the Lakes associations do do
provide um a benefit when it comes to
cyano bacteria and various other um
contaminants of con concern like storm
water they do provide feedback to us for
our rules but under this grant program
um The Advisory committees would would
um you know it basically be a pass
through Grant to those to those Rivers
advisory committees and they would be
able to um you know administer it and
and provide a benefit in the form of um
you know cleanup activities and
activities around um
uh contaminants of concerns so um I and
I can I can get more information to the
committee I wasn't prepared to talk
about this one specifically today so I
can get I know obviously I understand
what the uh R local River Management
advisory committees do but um happy to
provide more information about the bill
itself self in and in the fiscal note I
see there's a there's a revised one that
that came in so I can get some more
information if that would be helpful do
you know anything about how they get
fund how first of all how much funds do
they all these such
committees have in their in their
budgets and then where does that come
from are these federal grants are these
local property taxes are these I can get
you uh a listing of any of the yeah
donations uh likely for a lot of these
but I can get you an accounting of of
any Pastor grants that we currently
provide to them if that would be helpful
and uh any of the federal grants that
they might receive um you know there's
there's not a whole lot of funding for
this this type of activity in the state
currently so um this would provide a
benefit although it is it it is $40,000
so um you know of and it looks like it
would be a general fund expense so you
know I obviously I know the committee's
grappling with thank thank you Mr
chairman
thank you for coming in um just U you
know the chairman mentioned that this
would be new funding and I I agree it
would be new funding but you know in the
bill it talks about the fact that this
would be funding that would allow the
the the committee to fulfill the
responsibilities that were established
in statute so um you know if we're going
to if we're going to ask somebody to do
something you know theoretically we need
to give them the resources to do it
right and he's going to find out if
they're already getting some any sort of
resources from from us we administer
many different programs so I want to
make sure I get you the correct
information okay representative R and um
I would also be interested in learning
um some of the resources they provide
the department um for example I know in
in certain Lake Associations water set
associations they do a lot of testing
they'll deliver samples to the state um
I suspect the rivers commission's
probably do the same thing where they
might be sampling for cyano bacteria
that are in rivers um and you know
probably doing some projects on for
example Culvert replacement or Culvert
maintenance that actually saves the
state from expending those funds on
those projects that's right we do most
of our sampling efforts you know this
our staff does them but uh we also get a
lot of that from volunteers from these
types of committees and lakes
associations so there there is an
extensive effort out there on a
volunteer basis to provide us
information about the water quality in
in the state and so there is an
extensive um effort there okay thank you
very much thank you all right
representative camell thank you Mr chair
it's it's a worthy cause and something
that I definitely would support but
given the current fiscal situation uh
I'm making a motion to retain for the
moment okay that second it set all right
representative cell moves to retain
House Bill 624 second by representative
Griffin any further
discussion okay all those in
favor okay looks unanimous thank you
very much
okay
good this one's
retained now do we have any more
Dees what do we have here Federal agency
transparency multi-use energy Hampton
Beach uh
which one Hampton Beach you want Hampton
Beach
okay 607 anyone here for that Bill yes
there he
is he can't vote on he can't vote on his
own
bill all right representative
Ms a whole $10,000
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee it's it's nice to see you from
this
perspective particularly representative
rung and representative leechman who I
don't have to look sideways to um just
for for the record my name is Chris muns
I am um one of the um four
representatives from Rockingham District
29 which represents the town of Hampton
I I'm handing out the uh testimony that
I provided to the uh resour resources
Recreation and development committee um
when I introduced this bill and also um
a letter of support from um my colleague
representative Nick bridel who also is
from Hampton and who sits on that
committee um just give you a quick uh
some quick background the U Hampton area
Beach commission was established in 2003
by the um legislature it's an oversight
commission that helps the town of
Hampton and the state of New Hampshire
with long-term planning for uh the
Hampton Beach area it's made up of
members from the town State Hampton
Beach Village District the Hampton Area
Chamber of Commerce and the commission
is currently chaired by former state
representative uh Tracy Emich who I
believe is uh you all pretty familiar
with um and the vice chair is uh Pat
bushway who served in the house for two
years uh the commission's work includes
implementing the Hampton Beach master
plan um to do that the RSA says that it
should assist the town and state and
town in acquiring lands and rights and
lands assist the town in develop
building and Zoning codes codes provide
advice and counsel to the state and town
on planned you plan use
developments um consult with the Hampton
Beach area businesses and residents meet
at least
quarterly uh and meet at least annually
with the Selectmen and publisher report
um since its Inception the commission
has had um no funding to do any of that
um and this bill would provide the
commission with a small sum of $5,000 in
each of the two years to enable it to
carry out out its Duty um the mechanism
in the bill is that um we would be
creating a um Hampton Beach master plan
fund and then um that fund would be um
uh uh General funds would be
appropriated to that um every uh every
year in the amount of
$5,000 so I'm happy to take any
questions all right questions
representative s thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative for bringing
this uh legislation forward so I know at
the local level for towns and cities
when they go through a master plan
process the Consulting fees and the
costs are are usually north of
$150,000 so $5,000 a year for a master
plan for Hampton Beach is
adequate um
you know I'm quite honestly I'm not sure
where that where the funding for that
came from but I know that it has been
developed already this is really just to
allow the the commit the the commission
to just carry on its normal course of
business so is there sorry follow up go
ahead do we have other funds in the
budget already going towards Hampton
Beach not that not towards this
commission that I'm aware of no okay
thank
you all right and have has the um
commission asked the town for this money
or is that inappropriate somehow well
it's a state
agency um and um oh it's a state agency
I yeah it's not a town agency it's
established by state
law okay since it's exception 22 years
ago um so how how much money has gone
from the state to this Commission in 22
years nothing
nothing okay so why is this year
different
anyways representative wer I did have a
call
from excuse me from representative Emer
MSO saying please please pass this for
$110,000 and I agreed I would support it
okay so you want to make this motion
to to retain
it okay all right so uh representative
wer moves to retain House Bill 607
seconded by representative rung is there
any further
discussion no all right all those in
favor all right it's unanimous with uh
representative Ms abstaining okay very
good thank you all
right Mr chair yes representative
Stringham
um uh with with with your permission
gentlemen with your permission can we um
take take a look back at the um local
Rivers management
advisory grant
program okay I I just had 624 yeah I I
go ahead you want to just discuss it a
little more is it yeah I mean well I
mean I pulled up just some and I don't
know if these are things that have come
up if anybody else knows anything but
there is a New Hampshire Rivers
management advisory committee it looks
like it's very active and um uh does
some significant um uh tracking of
legislation and have ongoing Zoom
meetings I'm not sure if we were kind of
aware of that or um uh and
um uh you know and so the the committee
Grant is it to go to support this
committee or is it for purposes that
that they then would
um what it's the way the bill is written
is it create it creates 4 ,000 Grant
fund for two years but it says that no
individual committee can get a grant
larger than $10,000 okay so there has to
be a minimum of four grants made or more
okay right so it can't be just that one
I
guess yeah but um so are the and these
are organizations that have been helpful
to us so far that's what we're told but
Dees is going to get us some more
information represent run yeah I can
speak to that a little bit um this is a
Statewide um commission committee but it
it serves many local River associations
and I know in marac we have a San River
um uh committee we have marac River
committee I know the Mary meeting River
committee which I'm not quite sure what
town they're based in but they do a lot
of work because they've had they've been
impacted by cyano bacteria over the
years so these kind of Grants will help
them maybe to buy equipment to may take
measurements um help train volunteers on
some of the testing that's done because
I know in New Hampshire Lakes um those
associations not not New Hampshire Lakes
specifically but a lot of those local
Lake and Watershed
associations um perform a lot of testing
free through the New Hampshire lay lakes
program and that day feeds in to inform
Dees okay so I mean it will be
interesting to see the the information
that Dees comes back with but that's
it's it's very similar to the model we
have for supporting Lakes all right
let's move on here thank you so
um uh who's here for what let's let's
ask that
question okay why don't we start with
that then I'll spill 723
I don't see representative
Bry no have to do with me okay so I'm
Dan faen I am Regional policy director
at the department of energy here to talk
about HBS 723 FN um it is a repeal of
the Statewide multi-use energy data
platform uh repealing RSA 37850 50
through
54 um so that was those sections of law
were passed in 2019 and since then
there's been an effort to put together a
Statewide multi-use energy data platform
that would provide uh customers access
to their energy usage data and third
parties uh and utilities could use that
as well to offer a variety of services
um I'm here to speak about sort of the
different
in standard util utility practice and
what this uh the data platform has been
and the impacts that has had on the
Department's resources um typically a
utility makes an investment brings it
forward to the Public Utilities
Commission where it's reviewed by the
department and many other parties um to
determine whether or not the investment
was prudent the this bill sort of uh
shortcut that process and changed who
gets a say in the utilities uh
decision-making processes um and it's
been going on since 2019 it's involved a
a very you know hundreds of hours for
the Department in in Staffing time um
and just has been something that uh is
outside the normal of our standard
operating procedures um we prepared a
fiscal note that found a indeterminant
decrease in state revenues um that's
associated with Savings in energy costs
paid for by the state and this staff
time reduction that we would require if
the bill if the uh mandate was repealed
and I'm happy to answer questions about
the platform itself or anything you well
the am I looking at the wrong fiscal
note I I see as introduced is it is
there um I do not believe there's an
amended one this bill came through um as
introduced okay there's no so the fiscal
note I'm looking says nothing there's no
change to revenue but there is a
decrease in expenditures did I miss
speak you said Revenue I meant
expenditures okay so
um is is this to to what extent are
those decreases in
expenditures affect the the uh general
fund and Highway fund and and and to
what extent would they be known so this
repeal would likely result in a savings
for rate payers and the uh Associated
lower energy costs paid for by the state
um however that's an extremely difficult
calculation to make and we're unable to
provide an exact figure for that gotcha
so so all the little Parts in the house
bill one that say utility costs might go
down a fraction is is that kind of what
we're talking about here okay
representative Ms thank you Mr chair
thank you for coming in to try to
explain this to us um I was a little
confused by where you were going um with
your um a with your opening remarks I
mean um in terms of pro the pro the
process that you described
and and quite frankly trying to
understand you know is the Department of
support supportive of the multi-use
energy data platform or not supportive
could you clarify that a little bit yeah
we we are neutral this is a legislative
prerogative that uh was adopted in 2019
and if the legislature thinks it's
unwise we are we are an implementer so
we will we will stop imple implementing
uh but until that moment we we are
enacting the law and making sure that
these uh Investments are in the best
interest of rate payers represent mons
but um you you talked about hundreds of
hours that have theoretically or or have
been invested in this can you describe
what that is yeah so that is uh has been
over the the course of the period a
lawyer an analyst
um who have been pulled in from their
other obligations and have uh racked up
significant comp time uh in in this
process um it's been a very labor
intensive uh procedure um and that has
to do with the fact that this was
mandated as as a thing for the utilities
to do rather than the utilities deciding
it was a prudent investment and
defending that decision uh to the Pu
that that the the time that the lawyer's
been spending and the other staff has
that been
to respond to the utilities or to
prepare an RFP or you know what exactly
have they been doing yes and more um so
so it it's been to there there was also
a a couple of efforts to receive federal
funding for for the data platform that
were not successful um but there so
there was input uh into Federal funding
application
um there there's been development of an
RFP that should shortly be brought to
the Pu um things like that but it's been
it's been weekly uh for you know since
2019 it's been a very very intensive
process yes representa um you know my my
understanding is that what this platform
would do would be to
provide better more timely decision uh
data for decision making
is that an incorrect assumption there
are a number of potential benefits
associated with the a platform um there
there's been part of part of uh the
staff time has been related to figuring
out what exactly those are because the
the the Mandate doesn't um it requires I
forget the exact wording but um that the
the project be in the public interest or
um and I'm forgetting the exact phrase
that it's used um but the the benefits
are not uh clear at this time and are
subject to ongoing discussion yeah and
if you read the fiscal note it says this
would
cost five million or so dollars that
have not yet been expended right so I
think they decided not to go forward
with it is in the Science and Tech
committee all right represent Camal
thank you Mr chair yes having been on
Science and Tech I know this to be an
initiative that was really not worth the
what the potential cost is going to be
and I have a lot of confidence in my
colleagues and
st& uh and given the fact that again
we're in this fiscal crisis this would
be an excellent thing to uh to pass to
remove this cost to the to the rate
payers so oh and I'd like to make a
motion to OTP okay second all right so
move by representative Campell second by
representative Griffin to uh recommend
house bills 723 ought to pass and this
is
just as opposed to making it a section
in house bill to so um but since there's
not really a direct fiscal note then it
probably this is appropriate yeah
Melissa once yes I I would say this is
appropriate it doesn't seem like there's
going to be any cost especially if this
never went into play Then There Will no
there will be no change or decrease okay
everybody know what the motion is what
we're voting on okay uh all those in
favor okay looks like six and opposed
three very good okay so representative
cell will will write a
uh a blurb or or look one up from
previous time this came to the house do
I have to for division one well this
we're going to recommend pass so it'll
go to the regular finance committee
presumably we'll vote
It Go in the
calendar when's When's the full
committee meeting do we
know this afternoon a lot oh
okays but this is probably not on the
list yet so so it'll be next week
sometime or whatever okay I have you
okay huh Monday not this afternoon no we
have this
afternoon
1:5 it's Monday it didn't get the last
calendar okay well we have a conflict
then no I think it's Monday it's Monday
it's Monday it's Monday
okay
okay so not this
afternoon today is Friday
[Laughter]
there was there's a disconnect
there
okay I have your
blur yeah but it sounds like but this is
not yet in the calendar right so we
can't exact this on Mon
huh but but executing this particular
Bill who's on first right so it'll be
for whatever the next time the full
committee meets
okay all right fine to pass okay
good all right next does representative
any other Representatives here have any
more bills no representative Maguire do
you mind doing 511 next um if
representative Sweeney doesn't mind just
I did I'm trying to check with doj to
see if they're going to come in for 640
I haven't heard back yet so that will
just give them a little bit of time and
the other one on our list is 187
we did that one we did that one I just
didn't cross it off okay good okay oh
yes that's that was the first the first
lady who was here okay so let's do
511 so where is that one we got that
one representative Sweeny
yeah thank you Mr chair so just to catch
everybody back up so on 511 we had
gotten an amendment from the County
Association just to make the bill work
with the County correctional facilities
uh we reviewed the amendment I no issue
with adding the amendment in so I'm
actually happy to move Amendment
07858 uh I know it was handed out to us
a week or so ago I have it here
discussed it it it is a simple Amendment
it really just you know gives the county
cover for if they're holding somebody
under an ice
detainer okay so let's uh let's bring
the whole bill back to mind here so this
um represent Sweeny why don't you
explain the whole yeah so on on the
money side of this bill it was
indeterminable on the fiscal note uh so
there's really no real expenditures uh
the only note from doj when they did the
fiscal note is if the case load
increased significantly they may need
additional Staffing uh but there's no
indication that the case load would
increase significantly right no I meant
um for my benefit and the benefit of
Representative Stringham why don't you
explain the general G gist of the whole
bill so this is the bill that was taken
out of uh came out of criminal uh
justice and Public Safety unanimously
it's an amended version of the bill to
end Sanctuary City policies in New
Hampshire uh and they put in protections
to make sure that nobody would be
unjustly uh accused of of being here
illegally um so this just requires
cooperation of local departments with
Federal immigration authorities they get
past the house with 98% support I think
they're only six or so detractors gotcha
and is there a related there is no
related section of House Bill two right
the governor didn't no put any stand
alone gotcha all right so um
representative Sweeney uh moves
Amendment uh
0785 H is there a second second seconded
by representative wer
all right any further discussion of this
representative mutts thank you Mr chair
um you know I I have to admit I mean I
did vote for this in the house um um and
um but but you know a after after we we
discussed this um and heard the concern
Express I don't know who it was um who
brought forth the um who suggested that
we we make the
amendment um I i' I've I've had lots of
concerns about
um setting a precedent of holding people
that do not have a criminal charge
against them in our jails I think we're
it we're we're we're we're going on a
very slippery slope and um you know this
amendment it while it addresses the
concern that was raised it also sets a
precedent I believe that it and if you
look at the language that a detain that
it allows uh a county to hold a
detainee after the resolution of State
charges so in other words we're giving
the counties the ability to hold people
who have who have had no crime charged
against them and I just think that
that's a very dangerous
precedent I I can't support that we
already do most of the people in the
county jail are
pre-trial so they haven't been convicted
I I represent um thank you
representative wer I mean I think the
distinction is they have been charged
with a crime they're being held for a a
crime they may not have been convicted
but they're being held for a crime these
individuals will if if they have their
if their state charges have been
resolved and they're being held
they have not been charged with a crime
they're just being held and um again I
think we have to be very careful about
putting ourselves in a position where
basically anybody can be held in a
jail representative Sweeny and I don't
representative I don't want to get into
back and forth on the policy aspects of
this but these are only for individuals
with ice detainers in cooperation with
the federal government to so and my
response to I understand that it has to
do only with ice I understand that and I
guess my position would be if ice wants
us to hold them in a in a jail then they
should file a criminal charge against
them represent rung thank you um I
noticed that the representative from the
counties is here as I I was wondering if
she could comment on the amendment and
see if it addresses her concerns that
were brought up at our last meeting on
this
Bill thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee again Kate Horan for the
New Hampshire Association of counties so
this language is exactly what I provided
to the committee so IT addresses all of
our concerns thank you organ h o r g an
any questions for Miss
organ no representative
lean okay more discussion thank you very
much thank
you yes representative lean thanks Mr
chairman so my community has gained some
some notoriety recently because there
was a an arrest of four I guess illegal
aliens in Peterboro the town had passed
an ordinance some time ago that the
community would not work with ice and
detaining or helping so I'm going to uh
have to join representative Ms with my
concerns in supporting this bill okay
very good anybody else representative
run I just want to um thank Miss Horan
because I I'm glad that our counties
can't hold them without an agreement in
place so we don't the counties won't be
holding the bag for the expense of of uh
doing that so thank you okay so let's
vote first on whether we're another
comment yes represent I got a call from
the chairman of Rockingham County a
Commissioners saying they're they're
looking forward to having the same
agreement that I think two or three
other counties two other Counties have
because it's making money they getting
$160 a day and no medical cost right
from from the feds for for taking Isis
or whatever ice brings to them right and
and we've heard I I've heard informally
from uh people from Corrections that uh
we have extra space and conquered for
example and we should maybe consider
doing the same thing ourselves okay um
all right well in any case that's here
not relative to this bill but yes go
ahead thank you Mr chair and I do I mean
this did pass criminal justice I think
my vote today is just really going to be
on the fiscal impact but those concerns
have been addressed with the amendment
yes okay good so um we're just going to
vote on whether to adopt Amendment
07858 okay all those in
favor okay looks like seven and oppos
two okay very good so the amendment uh
passes now now uh I guess representative
Sweeney moves oop pass amended is second
representative wer seconds all right um
any further discussion no all right all
those in favor of opop pass with
Amendment okay we've got looks like six
and opposed three okay very good all
right
so um at some point representative
Sweeney will produce a blurp
and possibly others will as well okay so
that that's 511 are Melissa are we not
ready for for for
640 I have not heard back so it's your
choice if you want to continue we can
continue why don't we at least read it
and see what sorry Mr chair on that last
bill I mean I'm happy to do a Minority
Report okay very good represent when do
you need that well we when it gets on
the calendar for the full committee
which it won't be for Monday right right
so yeah it might be next week yeah it
might be could be Wednesday or some
other day Okay uh possibly Friday next
week I guess right so that makes
sense okay well number all right so next
is House Bill 640 relative to
transparency of federal agency
operations in New Hampshire what's the
legislative history of this bill Melissa
this one was introduced in criminal
justice and Public
Safety it came out of the committee OTP
9-7 and it went to the floor and was
passed on a Division vote 187 to
183 o very
close all
right
um and what is it let's see here
Attorney General a good
idea we've asked before how many uh
immigrants have been sent from the
border to New Hampshire and we don't get
a straight answer but we we've heard
from police departments that there are
some representative R thank you Mr
chair I think this is a real um
boondoggle of a bill because if you look
at the expenditures coming from the
general fund 230,000 Plus
in increasing through fiscal year
2028 and there's not even a requirement
of the federal agencies to provide this
data so we're going to spend all this
money on people and a website to put
this data up and it's going to give the
false sense to our constituents that
this is all the data but there could be
some agencies that don't provide it or
they're giving um obsolete data um I
voted against this on the floor it's
I just think with the tight budget we we
are dealing with to spend this kind of
money on data that's not complete or
reliable is really um throwing good
money after bad yeah well I would I
would say we probably should want to
retain this right and because of exactly
that right I mean we got
uh this is um if we put it into the
budget this would cost us46
$6,000 so representative
Griffin yeah I agree 100% And I will
move to retain it okay representative
Griffin moves to retain House Bill 640
representative Wier seconds any further
discussion no all right all those in
favor okay looks unanimous okay very
good all right that completes these
bills um Melissa do we have other I
don't know House Bill two things or
amendments anything ready that we should
talk about yes I'm not entirely sure uh
we only scheduled bills in the morning
so we didn't put budget work session
continuing I did not think you guys
would get through those bills that fast
so kud to you for sort of plowing
through all right well why don't just to
I think we'd be okay with the discussion
of the paper I handed to you this
morning right so why don't we do that
h no she's handing it
up so one of the ways that we can find a
little money in the budget is um with
the rooms of meals uh tax
distribution uh currently uh this is
roughly 140 million a year and um it's
part of the treasurer's budget um so I'm
propose I'm going to propose at some
point that we restructure it um in
general and it could be as RSA
31a right or it could be wherever
Melissa do we know where in in the rsas
this exists because I wasn't sure about
that sure it's currently I don't have
the exact RSA but it's under the M&R
distribution so it's under the meals and
rooms tax uh statute okay so do we know
what RSA that is we'll find out but
anyways it it could be as a
reconstituted RSA 31a it could be back
still where it is right now um but in
any case uh the proposal would be
um as as you see it on this paper so um
if we
distribute
um 25% instead of 30% that gains for us
in the general fund something like 22
million a year something of that sort
and that gets us partway to to our goal
for this
Division and then the then I'm currently
this money is distributed strictly by
population so it it works out to roughly
a $100 a person uh all through the the
state but to me I'm more sympathetic
to
um to places in the state that have very
low property values and so um so my
proposal would be the following three
points number one is we would ramp the
distribution by uh by the ratio of
property value per per person in that
locality right so if you look at the
um if you look at the spreadsheet and
and it it ranges from from roughly a low
of about
$100,000 uh worth of property per person
up to $7.5 million do of property per
person in the in there's there's one
location that has two people and $15
million worth of property which is a it
turns out it's it's not a ski area it's
a
landfill
[Laughter]
so it could become a who knows if they
have I don't know if they have a
mountain or whatever but that that that
place is appropriately named success
so yes it is um so anyways so so my
proposal would be that um there would be
a ramp and there would be a starting
point so so so places that have high
property value resources would not
receive this money like they do now so
right now we write a check for
$200 every year to the to to those two
people in success right well
so my proposal would be that we would
start at 150% of average property value
per population which the current average
is roughly
$240,000 of property per person so we
would start at say 360 obviously this is
for discussion only right so we would
start at a property value per person of
say
$360,000 and then we would ramp it up
toward the
um to toward the community that has only
$100,000 of of property per person if
you see what I mean so um and then so
anybody go ahead anybody over three any
town with more than 360 per person would
get nothing that's right okay that's
right and um which is a you know a
relatively small amount of people but
that's kind of where that 22 million is
coming from
if you see what I mean that yeah go
ahead ref you're only Distributing 150%
by this formula so the other 50% would
still go by population no it's not no
that's not um what what I'm talking
about so the amount distributed okay
instead of being 140 million would
be8 18 million say something like that
right but but the way it would be
distributed is places with greater than
roughly
$360,000 of property per person taxable
property right would get nothing and
people below that would get something
but based on a ramp based on a
um the the ones that yes go ahead
representative Griffin yeah I'll get you
a spreadsheet at some point talk about
you know the details the problem I see
with with uh your plan if I could call
it that is that towns really value you
know vary in in makeup and like I live
in a town that has absolutely no
commercial base all right and the town
next door to me has a huge commercial
base a lot of Industrial Engineer ing it
seems to me like you're going to have to
hire 10 people just to kind of come out
with how you how you how you treat all
that variation in property it's not just
a simple division you got to you got to
look at the type of properties and
everything else it gets very complex I
believe well the way the I mean this is
similar to the Statewide property tax
for example and it's just how much it's
treated by how much taxable property
there is in that place right so so a
house worth worth a million is similar
to a business worth a million in that in
that scheme now the house worth a
million has people in it right the
business worth a million has no people
and so that goes into the population
part of this formula right so anyways
let me go let me just get to the last
bullet point and then we can keep
talking if we want to or wait till we
see spreadsheets and get you know in
language and all that sort of stuff but
but the last bullet point is when you
look at the list
of uh the straightup list of population
versus property values okay there are
certain places that feel that on that
list look like they're very poor but but
my perception of those places is not
that they're they're quite so poor and
and um what the difference seems to be
is certain places have a lot of people
living in non-taxable
institutions okay in particular prisons
jails nursing homes and college
dorms okay so so I think it's an
appropriate adjustment to population for
for this purpose to subtract those from
the population and so um it it is not a
big number difference but it makes what
I perceive of the results to be more in
line with what I perceive to be
um places that have have serious
problems with their property tax
compared to others if you see what I
mean
so represent why so once you've
determined you're going to eliminate a
lot of towns the towns that the left
you're still going to distribute the
money by population yes is that correct
yes so Manchester will get a very large
amount of this and and uh I don't know
pick your favorite small
town
Peter gets lesser because there is a
population multiplier absolutely but
question is for Manchester what number
are you multiplying by compared to some
other town right EP right yeah go ahead
the the one I've got lots of concerns
but one one concern that I have with the
the last point that we were talking
about you know adjusting it for
population is um towns that have prisons
jails nursing homes and college dorms
they also have expenses that are
associated with those
entities um you know just because you
have a jail if you have a jail you still
have people that are using using the
toilet and putting press putting um
putting uh stress on your wastewater
treatment system and you know the rooms
of meals tax allocation to local towns
is to help with those types of expenses
so I mean I don't think you can say that
uh you know that you could you you
exclude those people because they don't
have any
cost right right but the the biggest
cost that Municipal municipalities have
is education right and um those
institutions do not
contribute um
children uh in the same way that
standard residences do right so so they
tend to have again they have lower
property tax rates than than otherwise
go ahead representative
R oh representative Stringham go ahead
yeah thanks I you know first of all this
this proposal deals with two things one
is uh uh cutting the distribution to
cities and towns uh from the meals and
room Stacks so uh no matter
where uh uh which which which town is
selected uh to not receive the money
we're talking about uh shift from from
uh uh state government to local property
tax somewhere uh and and can I interject
just for a moment sure okay we passed
the bill yesterday House Bill 739 pretty
strongly that did exactly that but go
ahead that was the uh excess swept
exactly
yes so this would be a uh uh a second
second Bill to uh essentially raise
money from the state which ultimately
will come from local property tax yes so
now now
um uh and that's kind of straightforward
and understandable I think when you get
into this
apportionment you know we have 400
representatives and 24 Senators we're
probably going to have somewhere around
424 different positions on on uh on uh
the way the any changes to the
apportionment formula um you know if I
was in uh Berlin or gorum where good 20%
of the population is in incarcerated in
both the federal and and or County and
uh state prisons up there I think
federal
prison um uh you know the the issue of
whether uh of uh whether to have uh uh
those individuals not count would be
pretty important to them um so and
um I I guess I'm I I guess I'm saying
playing playing with an apportionment
formula um uh is is a much uh more uh
complicated and probably uh fairness to
the process ought to be um uh done in
uh a more deliberative way to allow
people to understand what's what's there
uh formulate what their opinions might
be and get input to uh avoid uh
unintended consequences uh even more so
yeah um I will say one weird thing about
the data that I've received from the LBA
is that in the case of Berlin the the
list of who's in prison is zero so
there's something wrong with this
list that was I will take full ownership
of that I forgot to add that one in oh
okay you have a revised one toiled so I
apologize so so yeah um anyways we'll
we'll end up I I'll I'll get you this I
just wanted to hand this out so you can
start stewing on it right so but but
I'll get you the spreadsheets and the
before and after and all that sort of
stuff yes representative leean yeah
thanks Mr chairman I yes I do have a
couple of questions one you have nursing
homes are you thinking of just County
nursing homes could we have nursing
homes for instance in Peterboro and
they're I don't know if they're tax
exemp but certainly County nursing homes
but there are a lot of private nursing
homes that so I was just curious where
this non- taxable nursing homes came
from is that just County or it's mostly
County I believed what's on the list
Melissa do you know yeah uh we put in um
County and private and listed them
separately if you want to make the
distinction of whether keeping both on
there or removing them do we know
whether nursing homes that are private
are charged property tax or not I do not
know that is our County person that out
don't okay thank you yeah so my
intention would be if these are these
are residences that that are not t part
of the taxable property base right so if
they are or they aren't we would put
them in or not put them in caring
representative Ms thought
further um a lot of these so-called
institutions whether they're colleges or
um jails or prisons often calling the
municipality for help whether it's
police ambulance water sewer that type
of thing so they do certainly have an
impact but I would be curious when you
get
CH to make comparisons the final thought
and we've had this discussion before is
putting towns against towns you know
because you're going to have people that
is representative Griffins that live in
say a town like Mont Vernon that some
are rich some are poor same with
Peterboro it's not a general blanket
that there are people that are on both
sides of the scale even in these richer
communities so I think we have to be
careful that we don't pit right Town
against town I understand but
so let me just give you representative
cordelli for example he's a good example
okay he yesterday in his speech cited
his town of heam right and I looked it
up okay and this is a town with
$800,000 $820,000 something like that of
taxable property per person okay so but
it's quite possible that that and as he
said there are some people in that town
living in Mobile Homes right and but but
because their town has $800 and
something, worth of property per person
their tax rate is very low let's call it
I don't know what it is but let's call
it $10 a th000 something like that but
there are people in my town who live
in Mobile Homes but they're because the
rest of our town is not in the $800,000
range we're in the I don't know what it
is $200,000 range or something they're
paying a property tax rate of
$27,000 right so I don't think it's
unreasonable to when we're giving money
back to towns to do it in such a way as
to fav those places that have low
property values you know I mean it it's
that's like always you always get us
thinking okay so yeah all right we'll
start with representative Griffin then
representative wer and then
representative R yeah but I I go back to
the the fact that you're trying to treat
all property the same and and so if we
take instance of a uh a lake Lake
Community where you have a lot of Summer
people so you don't have a big year
round population you're taking a small
number into into a big
number all right and then you go to a
place like I live in mon Veron that has
a fairly High property value per
property but has a million kids and so
we have the highest tax rate in the
state because we got so many kids you
know and uh well but again you then you
would have a high population number you
do that formula it's not going to work
well well no but you would have a high
population at sounds like well it's not
simple we'll see okay not that simple
all right representative
W we're not going to pass this budget
without some new thinking and some new
ideas and I appreciate the concept um
what's going to determine whether or not
it passes is when you get through with
your thing you may have to adjust this
360,000
um property value per person up or down
cuz if you end up with let's say out of
these towns you get 60 towns that you're
going to leave out they're all going to
vote against it and some others may vote
against it on principle or because they
think they're getting a buck less um so
you'd have to look at see where you need
to put that 360,000 and probably get it
down to no more than sure maybe 10 15%
of the towns one of the been here long
enough I remember um I don't see North
Conway in here probably it's part of
Conway but they always argued that they
weren't getting a fair Shake on meals
and rooms because they had people paying
it in their Town more than any other
towns and were giving money to towns who
have no businesses collecting meals and
rooms so they North con Conway was we're
a donor Town we're were donor town the
big difference was all the money comes
into the state so nobody knows exactly
how much came out of their town where we
did the Statewide education property tax
everybody knew the dollar how much money
was collected in that town now we're a
donor town so we heard that for 10 years
so this I like the idea having a concept
I like the idea we got to grab all the
money we can from somewhere for the
general fund and you know people are
upset about the fact that there's a a
statement in the uh in the hb2 that says
the uh dis distribution Municipal
distribution will be discontinued it's
been in there since
2012 this is this is a different a
distribution thing that we left out a
long time ago because we didn't have we
needed the money in general fund so but
everybody looks at that and
misinterprets it yeah I think we got to
cancel that thing all together so we
don't have to keep put it in there all
right representative rang and then I'll
react go ahead okay thank you I I have
two questions Mr chairman one is it's
what are your desired outcomes from this
I mean you're decreasing the rooms of
meals tax distribution but what what are
your your goals from this proposal yes
thank you for that um
so as you know I'm I'm now a member of
the education funding committee and in
the education formula we have something
that's very very similar to this except
that the population involved is school
children only right it's not um it's not
everybody but
I don't I think that formula is
appropriate and that column in that
formula is appropriate right because we
do have property value per child is part
of the education funding formula and
places like uh Berlin
Claremont uh Charleston you know that
have very low property values get more
in our adequate education formula um
then
do wolfboro Tuftonboro Newcastle
Portsmith those kind of places right so
um and and I don't think that's un
that's inappropriate I mean I I just
think it I tend to think that places
that have a a lot of property value
because they are are Resorts or they
have lakes or they have things that
attract you know what one thing that
gets you high property value is is a lot
of second homes right and and we tax
they get taxes not even from New
Hampshire residents right I mean Mitt
Romney owns a fantastic home somewhere
in Lakes Region right and so he's paying
New Hampshire taxes but but you know to
the extent that that we could tax him
more and New Hampshire residents
less I I think we've we've done
something good so you know that's part
of it okay so if I can follow up on that
so your goal is to lower property tax
the local property tax rate for
communities that have a higher assessed
value and a lower population I mean
obviously it's going to be on a scale
but no the other way around oh so lower
property taxes for people that higher po
population you know excluding these
things um per per property value okay um
no I I like the out of thebox thinking
um but I really agree with
representative Griffin that the reason
we have a property tax issue is these
communities that don't have a lot of
great assessed value but a lot of kids
and um so it would it might if we're
going to think out of the box maybe it's
worthwhile to look at a multifaceted
proposal where maybe part of it is based
on on people per assessed value but have
a multiplier in there for um communities
which have let's say you know out of
that population a certain percentage or
School AG kids that's just one of my
things because you could have a
community um same
population same assessment but that one
community that has a lot of kids is
really not going to benefit as much from
this as a community without but I'll
tell you just in general the the well I
guess I don't know that this for sure
but but the the total number on the
adequate education spreadsheet is like a
billion right and the total number here
is 10 and something million right so
it's it's the scale of the two things
are quite different right anyways
represent M thank you um you know I just
want to Echo what what representative
Stringham said that you know I think
first and foremost we have to recognize
that if if this proposal were to go
forward we are going to be placing um
about $22 million of extra cost on local
property taxpayers because um you know
those expenses are not going to go away
so the local property taxpayers are
going to have to absorb that in in
addition of the concern I expressed
earlier about excluding you know prisons
jails and nursing homes I mean the other
thing that um and you know that I have
to bring up is you know since we're
talking about the rooms and meals tax
there's an inherent inequity in the in
the program right now and and
representative Wier U touched on it with
North Conway there are towns there are
towns and areas in the state that
generate significant amount a
significant amount of the rooms and
meals
tax who also as a result of that incur
significant additional expenses I mean I
can tell you in Hampton um we go from a
town of um
you know 13 14,000 in the in the winter
there are days in the summer when we
have a population of 100,000 and we have
to have additional police we have to
have additional fire and um we bring a
lot of extra Revenue to the state as a
result of that but we don't get nearly
compensated for the extra cost that we
incur um so I mean if we're going to
start playing around with the rooms and
meals formula you know I'd like to see
us do something about adjusting those
those kind of inequities um because it's
it's it's a real cost to our our local
property taxpayers well I'll push back
just slightly I mean you have a good
point but but um you do have in such a
place uh businesses tourist businesses
right and those things pay property tax
right and so some other
place might have you're right you have
very few people right but you do have
property values that reflect the values
of those businesses so anyways
representative string yeah be being that
Lincoln is the biggest part of my
district okay and um and and yeah there
are some very expensive homes you know
some of the businesses are uh people's
second bed bedroom that they uh rent
rent out to skiers via
Airbnb and they do collect uh uh meals
and room tax if they uh rent out less in
six months and they're they're pretty
good uh the state's pretty good at
enforcing uh finding those people and
make sure they understand what the rules
are and pay up they de deal very well
but uh and um and but but there are
people you know
making you know quasi you know working
wages minimum close to minimum wage
anyway and um uh and uh they they pay
property tax and there that Town's that
is already being affected if assuming uh
uh the bill that was passed yesterday
goes through because Linkin uh by the
old definition would would certainly be
a donor Town
um and um so you
know I I don't know whether we want to
reinforce and and uh you know TR try to
hit the same towns twice with two
different bills yeah I understand
representative uh wer then MS
strategy is this if we took 20 million
away from 140 million and then we showed
a spreadsheet every time would get less
every rep would vote against it if we
rejig the formula so that some in fact
get more then those would all vote for
it that you have to arrange your
formulas such that there are more that
get a there more getting more than less
getting less redistributing 120 million
that's left under a different formula
and if it redistributes where let's say
the majority of towns get a buck more oh
it'll all V for it right and and the way
to move that is that 150% number right
you could slide that to 200% or
something and that would have more of
the effect that you're talking about
represent mths so just one last last
point in my um in my exuberance about
the um talking about the inequities of
the current system yes I neglected to
just mention you know an example that I
wanted to highlight of what I was
talking about if you look at this sheet
Hampton um currently is getting $16
million in rooms and meals allocation
it's on page two and then you look at
Milford and um I just you know no
offense to anybody in Milford um
milford's getting 1.6 million as well
okay I would I would I would submit that
Hampton is bringing in significantly
more in rooms and meals tax in than
Milford and also incurring significantly
more expense associated with that mhm so
that's just an example of the inequities
okay and and and we'll we'll look at the
before and after for those two places
and see what happens yes representative
leash representative Griffin and I are
quite familiar with Milford as I grew up
there but milford's got a huge
commercial base that pays huge money
into the uh business profits and
business Enterprise tax we have or now I
live in Peter brose you know but Milford
has a huge uh industrial base and I've
heard for years that milford's
contributing all this money to the state
like other cities and they're not
getting what they should get back
because milford's the Hub you've got
Mont Veron with no commercial activity
up there Brook line around it so
milford's H like Peterboro is a hub
where they have restaurants and other
businesses and again I think I commend
you for what you're suggesting because
it gets us thinking but the Department
of Revenue Administration this is
something I've asked the commissioner
many times why don't they keep track of
what comes out of each Community from
business Enterprise business profits and
rooms and meals because we have no idea
how these uh break down as far as a
contribution to the state conference but
okay I'm looking forward to your spread
right well I I'll let the representative
rang have the last word here okay think
oh that's
special um I think in your analysis Mr
chair
it may be easier if we excluded your
last bullet as far as the prison jail
nursing homes college dorms I agree with
uh representative leean about I I don't
know how you would really get an
accurate number on that and a lot of the
populations in those institutions change
so frequently and how how do you how can
we be assured of accurate numbers when
that calculation is is going on and the
other thing I want to mention two
following what representative Lehman
said about um commercial industrial
versus uh residential I mean maram we've
got a nice balanced tax base with
commercial industrial we have Fidelity
we have anheiser Bush my favorite um and
but the the problem is is what we've
seen at least in my town is our
residential property assessments have
been
skyrocketing and at a much higher rate
than commercial industrial so even
without any in extra spending on
municipal or town our taxes have gone up
because of that ratio has changed so
residentials taking a bigger piece of
the pie so I'm not really sure if the
element of that um would come into play
with this right so the Dr creates um an
and um what is it called equalized
property value uh because certain places
you reassess this year and other places
next year and so on so they they adjust
all of the property values in the state
to come up with an equalized value for
every location so theoretically those
things are are equal evened out but but
what you just described namely uh the
value of residential property has grown
faster than the value of commercial
property that's just a matter that the
market has gone that way right and and
so it does shift um property tax more
onto residences and less onto businesses
but that's simply because you
know we try to tax the Constitution
requires us to tax things
uniformly right and if it happens that
residences are worth more than
businesses that just happens you know so
and just because I do want the last word
um you know and and that's sort of an
outfall of the housing crisis that we
really haven't um we it it really hasn't
been a major point of discussion but if
communities around miramac grew their
housing we would have probably lower
property taxes uh home property taxes
because there's not that demand for
housing so it it's not necessary that
marac has to build more housing even
though we have built a lot of housing
but other communities by by addressing
the housing uh crisis regionally by
state it will lower property taxes for
all because then the demand will go down
um the values will go down and then it
will shift more of that piece of the
assessment pie on to commercial
industrial sure okay we will come back
at
1:15 um should Republicans have a lunch
maybe I treated by me oh you you want to
do that yeah okay you can have it
delivered where is it going to be that
we can have a caucus and I was thinking
common man what do you think of
that I brought my lunch but to insist
can I
CH
yes only if it's
permanent we have to revisit Sanctuary
cities Chris if we're gonna do
that okay what's
that
e
e e
all right we can get started it's
15 um so anybody here not here to talk
about group two
retirement no everybody okay anybody
here who is not representing a group or
organization and or is not themselves a
member of tier
B no okay so now we know who we are okay
um who uh who did you guys make a make a
idea for presentation
who's going to go first all this sort of
stuff okay all right
Brian please introduce
yourself thank you Mr chair for the
record uh my name is Brian real I
represent the professional firefighters
of New Hampshire approximately 2,000
active and retired firefighters across
the state uh just over I somewhere
around 500 5 550 of which I believe are
are caught up in the group t uh group
two tier B that we're discussing today
um not going to try and take up a ton
ton of your time but first and foremost
thank you to this committee uh in this
division for all of the work that you're
you're putting in not only with this one
singular issue but just across the board
with with a budget I'm not going to
pretend to understand what it takes to
that goes into that uh to get a balance
budget out of the house so um I really
appreciate you taking the time to listen
to all of us um and I recognize that
we've done this song and dance before so
um certainly I'll try and keep it brief
but we do have some new members yes
that's fair that's fair um so first and
foremost I I we don't need to I think
rehash the issues of of 2011
representative Maguire I believe you
you've done a pretty good job of that
already um but I do think there was a
has been a couple of things discussed
that we might be able to address uh any
questions or concerns over um and that's
the intent here today um first and
foremost it was uh mentioned that
there's been two major changes uh that
were made in 2011 to the pension system
for group two tib um in fact there's
been dozens of changes that were made um
that significantly altered benefits to
the range of 20 to $30,000 depending on
um how how how many hours you work and
um you know how many years you put into
the system uh obviously each individual
case is different uh but what we've
determined is that that equates to uh
thousands of dollars uh for members that
had benefits cut uh after working in
some cases 9 years and 11 months those
benefits were cut um so I just think
it's important to know uh the group that
we're speaking of doesn't have a lot of
angst over uh one or two minor changes
it has been a whole Myriad of things
that have cut their benefits um the
other thing that I think is important to
note because I recognized there was a
lot of discussion the other day about uh
the Goodwill in trying to fix some of
these issues for tier b i acknowledged
that uh that is 1,00% true uh both the
house and the Senate and the governor uh
tried to do some things to incrementally
restore some of these benefits uh we
haven't we haven't gotten to where the
ultimate goal is and that's a full
restoration of these benefits uh but we
have made some incremental changes
what's important to note is members
across Public Safety in tier a and tier
C both still currently have the benefits
they were promised upon
higher all members in tier a and all
members in tier C are going to
effectively retire with the benefits
they were promised it is the tier B
group that has since changed from the
date their date of hire um so while I I
recognize and I agree with the fact that
I think down the line we're going to
have to look towards uh
some modifications to tierc to make the
retirement more uh palatable
and um reasonable for people to come
work in New Hampshire they were hired
under the
terms uh that that they're going to
retire with uh when they're eligible the
other piece to note is they are not
eligible for retirement until the year
2037 so if there is going to be I'll use
the term that's been thrown around
enhancements to their
benefit um there is plenty of time to
look at that uh to look at how we make
our retirement system better the tier B
group is now be becoming eligible for
retirement and what we're seeing is that
those that are becoming eligible for
retirement are leaving
which is different than the way it used
to be where each additional year of
service Beyond Your Service
eligibility is worth sticking around for
because it makes your benefit better
each year that you work um what we're
trying to do is we're trying to stop the
Hemorrhage and we're trying to fix this
trb group to keep them here in
service beyond their years that they're
required to be here which I think is
incredibly important especially
where we talk about and this is true in
the private or public sector and I'm
sure most of you would agree with this
the best form of advertisement for
any uh industry is the people that work
there and that can advocate for it we
truly believe and this I can only speak
from the firehouse side but the
firehouse kitchen table is where we get
everything done and that's why this has
become no longer an anecdotal problem
because we around the firehouse table
every single day and we talk about this
problem um and it's perpetuated by
people that feel as though they were
they were injured back in 2011 and
they're frustrated and they're
disappointed in the system and I truly
believe that if the state makes good on
the promise um that these employees had
when they were hired that that is going
to be the best form of advertisement to
change that narrative at that Firehouse
kitchen table and it's going to
encourage t C people to stick around
because TC people are now going to know
the state has their back too and I think
that that's that's important I know the
differentiation between be T tier B and
tier C has been kind of under dispute I
just wanted to share
that um let me ask you you said 550
members are in tier B is that roughly 50
to 60 per year or is the the longer
serving members are they starting to
retire and
therefore it's it's it's sort of front
loaded or something at the at the
slightly I don't know the answer to that
I'm going off of uh numbers that we had
last year during the retirement
commission when they had that breakdown
and the retirement system may have some
idea but I don't know what range that is
um I do know we have had a significant
number that have left prior to their
eligibility um because at the time when
these changes were made and I'll speak
for me personally uh I didn't really
understand man the impact of it until
you as you get older in your career you
start actually putting pen to paper and
doing some numbers and realizing okay
this is this is a problem and now you
work with someone who knows finances and
they and and trying to determine if it's
worthwhile to leave now leave my money
in the system and go work in the Private
Industry or to stick around and I think
people are weighing that difference okay
questions from the committee I I had one
other sorry I had one other yeah sorry
um one of the the things that has been
brought up not just in this division but
across the board is the term spiking and
I recognize The Angst that there is with
that term um first I know the New
Hampshire retirement system does not
recognize that term it is not defined in
RSA 100a it's more of um I think kind of
a a a conversational piece than anything
else I understand why there is
is difficulty accepting someone who gets
paid out at a higher pension I I
completely understand that what I would
like to draw attention to is
a the way that we fund our retirement
system and our rates is a percentage of
payroll so I personally pay 11.8%
towards my retirement that is whether I
make $50,000 a year or if I make
$150,000 a year
that money goes into the retirement
system and the retirement system invests
that money and that
is that the Investments are one of the
ways one of the the biggest ways that
they pay out benefits at the end of my
career um so whether again whether I
make 50,000 or 150,000 it is a
percentage of that payroll um so I am
still paying into the system that amount
the employers are still paying into the
system that percent their percentage
which is somewhere around 30% now
um so it's not damaging to the system in
a sense that we are still paying money
into the system okay the other piece to
that is whether I work it in my last say
three years or five years of service or
somebody works it in their first three
or five years of service money is being
paid into the system okay cities and
towns have a minimum Staffing standard
that they
meet these are hours worked if if
someone is out sick and I and I am there
left to cover the shift whether I elect
to cover it or I'm forced to cover it
under mandatory Provisions I'm working
those hours these are not in uh
artificially inflated numbers these are
hours worked so members that have a
higher pension it's because they
physically showed up and worked 70 80
hour weeks okay so it's not again it's
they're not just artificially inflated
numbers
um and the last piece of this is there
are regardless of where we go this year
there are and will continue to remain
safeguards in place for quote unquote
spiking um they are in law now we're not
asking to change them it's different for
for different people based on the year
um that you were hired but those caps
still remain in place and we're not
asking asking to change those okay
represent Ms thank you U Mr chair and
thank you for coming in on this
beautiful Friday um with regard to the
the overtime and the on the in the on
call pay um isn't isn't it true that
some of that or maybe a large part of
that is due to the fact that we have
chronic
understaffing um across the Departments
and so we've got like a it's it's it's
almost like a a cycle we don't have
enough people so we have more overtime
so maybe more people leave um isn't that
part of the issue yeah thank you for the
question representative absolutely um
what we're finding
is uh the incentive to want to work the
overtime is not there so we're having
difficulty filling these shifts and
again cities and towns have M mandatory
minimum Staffing standards that they
must meet
so if we go through an overtime list and
reach out to everyone to say hey would
you like to work the overtime no would
you like to work the overtime no
everyone gets offered an equal
opportunity to work those shifts if they
choose not to others are being forced
into those positions so um it is it's
hard when just the regular day-to-day
when someone takes a day off let alone
if we are underst staffed because we
can't recruit or retain Personnel now we
have five six seven vacancies so we're
holding someone every day we're forcing
them to stay but on the back end we're
advocating that they their pension
should not reflect that followup yes go
ahead yeah and and to that point I mean
um and one of I'm one of the reasons we
have
vacancies is because of this uh concern
that people have about their benefits
and their overall pay package correct
correct yeah knowing that you can go
work in a um in an industry where you're
promised certain benefits and those
benefits can be taken away uh up to 9
years 11 months 29 days um it's really
disconcerting for people to want to come
in and and work in the
state all right representative uh wrong
followed by lean okay thank you Mr chair
and thank you um we heard public
testimony Wednesday today um and a
specific testimony that in intrigued me
regarding this issue was from Sergeant
selli I believe that's his name from the
na oh from the National Police
Department thank you very much for
sending that written testimony along but
one of the um issues that this presents
is around retention which you've touched
upon and the fact and I think in
Sergeant Chelli in your testimony you
mentioned how changes in the benefit
structure of Massachusetts has
incentivized officers leaving New
Hampshire to go work in
Massachusetts and um do you have any
more information on that let's say for
other states or if it applies also
equally to
Firefighters I'm sure um so what I can
provide you that's not just Word of
Mouth answer is that the New Hampshire
fire academy runs a test and it's the
candidate Physical Agility Test it's a
test you're it's an entry-level exam
that you're required to take to be a
firefighter in the state of New
Hampshire uh prior to 2011 there were uh
approximately 500 to 600 candidates that
would take that test a every year we're
down to about 200 per year now and if
you look at the chart that they've
provided uh it has been a s uh
significant downtrend since 2011 you can
see the delineation where it has slowly
trickled down since that date um and the
state has
since the the department of safety has
since done a recruitment and retention
uh study in which they specifically
highlighted these changes to the group
two uh tier B system as a uh as one of
the many albeit fixes to uh Recruitment
and Retention in the state um if you
want to speak to the other PD side so I
have a unique perspective because I
spent 13 years in Massachusetts uh law
enforcement before I came up to New
Hampshire uh I can tell you in those 13
years I never saw one New Hampshire
police officer certified officer come to
Massachusetts to work uh in the last
since 2011 the statistics I pulled from
um our recruiting division we've had 27
now leave New Hampshire and go south or
to federal agencies uh and we never saw
that before uh 2011 and like I said I
was in Massachusetts law enforcement
from 94 to 07 and we didn't see anybody
coming to Massachusetts from other
states to to work there in massachusett
has recently uh reduced their residency
requirement Civil Service requirement so
half your Police Department can just be
an application to get hired there so
that's the spike and we're seeing people
going down south uh because the the
retirement benefits uh are currently
greater there than they are here and
that's a primary reason we do exit
interviews with every uh employee that
leaves and that's the primary reason why
they say they're leaving to go to law
enforcement uh from our law enforcement
to another uh municipality uh job in
another state let me let me ask you
before representative leechman you said
27 moved to Massachusetts over what
period of time uh since 2011 but we've
had 70 leave prior to uh um retirement
age but those 27 which albeit seems
minuscule because it comes out to about
two a year that's 27 more than we had
pre 2010 sure but how
many how many are in each Year's total
number of officers is it unfortunately I
don't have that number but I will say CU
he had 550 so we we're seeing we're
seeing more and more each year because
those those uh Ease on restrictions have
uh come in the last uh couple of years
so it's we're seeing more in the last 5
years than we have prior to that so back
in 2011 I think it might have been one
uh we had a couple years with zero but
uh I know this year alone 20 24 this
past year I want to say we had six so
it's it's it's increasing but I'm under
the impression there's more police
officers than there are firefighters is
that right in the in this group I I do
believe so yes yeah but I don't have the
exact I know 1821 when we started all
right representative
lean thank you Mr chairman so I do have
a couple of
questions um as you know the retirement
commission that met suggested a number
of changes which were some adopted in
1647 which the Senate took up about half
of that uh and looking through house
bill to this year and I want to make
sure I'm correct in this assumption it's
just taking care of the group to that
tiered if you will tier B and there's
nothing for tier C because one of the
things we put in 1647 that myself and
representative Maguire uh sponsored was
also to take care of tier C and I guess
my concern is because there's nothing
for tier C the issue of retention comes
up because they're not getting the same
level of benefit of those people that
were vested before 2011 and of course
that group that you're in so how does
that stand how are we going to take care
of the t uh tier C's when those people
don't have the same benefits that you
have and the people be
behind thank you for the question uh yes
so as you'll recall with the commission
uh the commission was born out of uh
House Bill 436 which was originally a
bill much like the one we're looking at
today uh to restore all the benefits for
tier B that was how this all started
this division uh voted in favor of those
Provisions uh Full House Finance voted
in favor of those provisions and that's
what passed the house floor 282 to 80 um
we're essentially what we're talking
about today a full restoration for tier
B what had happened when the Senate
stripped it out was it was replaced with
the commission uh which you and I both
served on that commission um it it was
already determined at that point that
the provisions of House Bill 436 were
not palatable by the Senate and so
whatever we were going to get done was
going to be far less than that uh and so
we worked through it as a commission uh
obviously uh the group that wanted to uh
pass the the the bigger changes was in
the minority at that point in the room
did not it was not palatable uh to the
rest of the group and so we landed on uh
Provisions for 1647 which would impact
tier B and tier c um it was what we were
able to get done at the time it was we
knew the best that we were going to be
able to do but it also was a positive
incremental change and it was helpful to
start to to do that so that we could
have the conversation we have today
right because the changes that we want
to make now become cheaper because we
have made the the changes of the past
now as for your question for tier C I
can tell you uh everyone in this group
that represents a uh Public Safety
organization also represents members in
tier c um I have to go back and answer
to those folks as well um what I can
tell you is they fully understand
probably not 100% across the board but
largely they understand the importance
of fixing this tier B issue
before we address the tier C stuff
because tier B we looking to restore
what was taken away tier C is in fact
anything we give them an added benefit a
new
benefit the tier B changes The Tib
restoration is not a new benefit it is
restoring their old benefit and so they
understand the importance of fixing this
disparity first so that in 5 10 years
down the road we can have the
conversation about whether or not we
need to enhance or make that benefit
better it that conversation will
probably happen sooner than five years
down the road let's be honest um in
order to uh continue to retain but again
we have time it's 2036 2037 before they
can retire now
Additionally the the bill as written
does have a provision in there for or
for vesting or did have a provision in
there for vesting um which would say
that you could not lower someone's
benefit after three years of service
that would in fact be a significant
change for tier C because then they in
my opinion can rest their head on the
pillow at night knowing that this will
never happen again and we'll never have
to come back and address benefits that
were taken
away um anyone you're all set okay um
now you described this what what we have
in House Bill 2 as full restoration for
tier B but but my understanding is that
would mean making them the same as tier
a
right essentially yes I I I think we're
very very close to tier a there are some
some differences there um so we wouldn't
because I don't read the bill as making
you know a tier a b and a tier C if you
see what I mean
right there's still an ABC in here okay
um somebody can speak to that question
okay great okay thank you other
questions from the committee no all
right let's go you want to say something
if I may uh just those stats and the
numbers of the 27 that I was throwing
out that's simply for nasua that's not
okay I just want yeah two two for the
state would be great but
uh yeah no that's that's just NASA by
sure and and maybe people from NASA it's
more it's easier for them to move to
mass start working in
Massachusetts than it would be somebody
from Lincoln or whatever right so yeah
potentially yeah yeah okay very good or
Manchester yeah all right thank you
gentlemen so who would like to speak
next
good
afternoon uh my name is sa regasa I am
the President of the New Hampshire group
to retirement
Coalition uh this is a coalition which
represent the 1,800 employees now that
number had dropped
to 1,600 employees uh as of July
2023 so
um I would start by addressing couple
things uh I know represent ative uh
months have asked about this
overtime my agency is Department of
Corrections and currently we are at 45
plus per
vacancy as you all know there was an
initiative from the state that offer
$10,000 hiring incentive for those who
comes in to work for the state and that
incentive has stopped with that uh
10,000 bonus we weren't able to move the
needle and we're around right now at 45
plus percentage I don't want to speak
the exact number but I know it is 45
plus
percentage under any circumstances if it
was a private business that business is
under the
water
so the overtime at the Department of
Correction is the major reason that most
people get tired and most people are
afraid to come and work for the state of
New Hampshire Department of
Corrections people get to work four five
forced overtime now I am the part of the
Department of Correction my job I'm a
chief probation par officer when the
prison is under staff when they have
National Guard or after the National
Guard left we will be required to go
assist and I ran I very rarely would
work less than three over times a
week but the regular people
would have to work there and the way how
overtime work is it's a forced overtime
they can't refuse because if they refuse
there will be discipline for refusing a
forced overtime so you are an individual
and mostly young person and they come in
to work for Department one overtime no
problem good money I'll go home with
more money two overtime no problem by
the third day now you are cutting your
tie with your family members with your
community stakeholders with everyone
that you need to connect to
so we force people to work this overtime
and now in addition to that as Brian
explained in addition to that we also
charge them to
pay additional money the more money you
make the more contribution you pay for
TOS to the new hire retirement not only
the individual but also as the state so
as far as spiking I understand the
concern as a taxpayer I wouldn't want no
spiking people who never put their money
to take money from the state but the
reality is this is actually people pay
way more money to the retire in system
when they work more hours retention
issue representative
Rec right now what sustain my agency
Department of Correction is retention if
we were to pull or if we were to annoy
the current members including myself
that I have now my 23rd years was
Saturday last Saturday we're still
kicking around we still helping our
brothers and sisters and I don't think
anyone is capable of leaving them while
they are under 45% vacancy
rate but if we were to take out the
people that are currently there and
eligible to retire in the next five or
six years we are going to call National
Guard for the fourth time to the prison
ground and the last I check the good
Governor have refused to even send them
for the first time because he did it
three times and that's not really when
you send the National Guard at the
prison things don't run the way how they
are supposed to run that's not the
preferred method of watching
Correctional Facility by a trained
military personnel they have other use
they have other obligations to do it's
just a wrong practice in my
opinion but in addition to that years
ago we used to be able to teach I teach
at Southern New Hampshire University I
lecture classes in criminal justice
department we'll have 25 student every
year and we'll be able ble to snag five
six of them to come to work for the
state and this year I have 25 students
and none of them wants to come and be a
law enforcement officer in state of New
Hampshire so we are in a position where
we're not recruiting we're going to lose
the people who are sustaining who can
leave uh the average of people that I
talk to have at least five more years to
work I think we need these people who
would retire in the next 5 years way
more
the people who were not even eligible to
retire until 2036 is the retirement
system is broken before 2012 there was
an issue and that's why those preventive
measures were put in place but as one of
the masterminded of that change
acknowledged with 436 that went too far
under normal circumstances any of you in
here if you tell me that you'll be
perfectly okay after I promise you I
signed an agreement and I gave you a job
off and 9 years later to come back and
say h whatever I told you was you know
false and now I'm going to change it
nobody would be no human being will be
happy with what was done in 2012 but
let's take it one step further what good
comes out of it really we lost
significant amount of money we lost
paying overtime we lost significant
amount of trained Personnel the state of
New Hampshire become a recruitment Depot
to the surrounding State and I say that
because we hire people we train them
only when they have one year and two
years to say you know what I'm going to
go over the board and I'm going to work
20 years and retired with the highest
retirement in massachusett Maine
Vermont so there was no win-win solution
for it and I can understand it wi it was
able we were able to stop what was
intended but I think it had gone too far
it has gone too far we're not retaining
the people and I and understand this is
a priority to the good
Governor I say that because this is a
difficult time for a state of New
Hampshire aside from my job I represent
my Workforce and I negotiate contract we
don't expect much change this year as a
state employee because the state is in a
difficult place the state is even in a
more difficult place when we could lose
people who are capable to retire who are
able to retire because we continue to
reject this idea of honoring
what was they were
promised as Brian indicated previously
when you change the condition of
employment to tier a employee it will be
pension sweetening or adjustment the
benefit they didn't have the same thing
for the C it's pension
sweetening but when you give to the
people that were affected under the
certain condition that was taken
unfairly and we know it was unfair
because I can ask any of you if it was
fair if if it was done to you you tell
me it wasn't so if it was done unfairly
and we have an Avenue to restore and
retain the people we have which we
desperately need and I'm only talking
about Department of Correction Personnel
we desperately need to retain these
people that are capable of retiring
so I think it would be a win-win
solution if we can establish that
mechanism where we continue to retain
the people that we would lose
otherwise and question okay thank you
representative
thank you for coming could you explain
to me about overtime so this forced
overtime is it usually for two hours or
is it four or is it a whole
shift told me one time that the typical
payroll had 3 to four hours of overtime
in a twoe payroll with with Department
of
Correction the the force overtime is8
hours it's not like a business where you
do 2our you went home so you have to man
The Post you have to cover the post so
when you get forc you forc for 8 hours
so it's a 16 hour day and you multiply
that three and four times a week it is
exhausting it's eight hours it's not two
hours it's not three hours it's eight
hours all right represent
leash thanks Mr chairman and thanks for
coming and you said something that got
my attention with your criminal justice
class you like 25 people in there and
you can't get anyone interested to come
and work for the state in Corrections or
uh maybe police work uh so which leads
me to the question I asked earlier of Mr
will on the
retention these are new people they're
not interested in coming to the state so
if we don't make modifications to
tierc how are we going to attract new
people coming to the state because one
of the things that concerns me a lot and
representative wer and I were here back
in 2008 2009 when we were not in the
worst situation that we are now I think
we're in a lot worse financial situation
as a state now so how do we bridge that
as you mentioned you can't get anyone
interested now so without making
adjustments to say tears I think those
who are smart enough to join in criminal
justice division they understand what's
going on and my question to all of the
students is what is a reason why why to
waste your time and energy if you're not
going to be a law enforcement officer in
this state my uncle had to leave his job
after 14 years working with a state to
another state and relocate his family
because they Chang his pension away from
that was a testimony of one of my
student and and and as a matter of fact
I was the professor of that class and
that was done the same thing to me but
obviously I couldn't tell them we need
help we wanted to get help but it's also
the word of mouth like we are senior
most of these people that have been
affected by the by the change in 2012
these are your captains and lieutenants
and Chiefs who are currently training
people and keeping people here I think
making them happy goes a long way to
retaining the people we have right now
was that bad experience I don't think
it's going to help even if you you have
people coming through the door yeah they
take the $10,000 and we spend $100,000
for on them they leave because we never
forget what was done to the senior
people they change the benefit as of
right now there is nothing there is no
mechanism to stop the state from
changing the employment condition
because of what was done in 2012 I think
fixing it will send a message if the
state during difficult time change
condition the state will honor its
commitment that goes a long way I think
to me that's more important than uh the
numbers that we are seeing coming in as
it is we're not competing with other
state anyways to begin with thanks thank
you thank you chairman other questions
well I ask you about yourself personally
so you work your regular five shifts you
have three overtime shfs you um told us
you you teach this class at at SNH you
you're the head of your organization I
see you're wearing a wedding ring so how
how do you have
time and I I I may I I may add I am one
of the very few lucky correction
Personnel who kept my my marriage
okay um thank you for acknowledging that
very busy time most of these extra
overtimes that I work and and I'm not
kidding I'm going to go change my
clothes when I'm done and I'm going to
go stand the post at the prison this
afternoon I have friends that started
working in correction most of them I
have trained they will call and say hey
I am below critical numbers that I
needed to cover the shift would you be
able to come and those are not an easy
thing you can just yeah no I don't care
about you m so most of these calls come
not I voluntarily sign believe me I got
plenty going on in the community to deal
with I got plenty provisioners and
police but some of the calls that come
in from the person hey I give for for
the fourth time would you be able to
bail me out today that's how those calls
come in uh the voluntary ones over the
weekend when you have time yes but most
of the time it come from dire need a
friend and a brother calling to another
brother and asking I'm getting forc for
the fourth time and five the fifth time
can you help me and those are very hard
ones especially in the line of work we
have where we depend on one another
those are not an easy task to say and
believe me I rarely sleep a 6our sleep
rarely which anyone can agree that
that's not normal so and multiply that
by the number of people who are working
at the prison and it's not only the
prison issue it affect every law
enforcement where they don't have a
Personnel to actually cover all the
shifts and there is another part I I
want you all to understand it's not
normal for a police officer to say hey
you know what we only have two police
officers in this town today so we can't
cover we don't speak about these issues
in public it's like alerting burglars go
ahead and start burglarizing other
people it's the same thing for Brian he
can't say you know I only have two
firemen today I can send to respond it's
like alarming the public safety for that
reason for 10 plus years people have
been quiet about these issues generally
our line of job we can't really speak in
public about it but when it is enough
it's enough and I think we're are
reaching to that point okay and our
Public Safety needs to representative R
thank you Mr chair Mr chair you you
touched on a really important issue and
you did too is when we have forced
overtime like that um yes it puts a
strain on marriage but I was once in a
workplace where we had a lot of overtime
time and the children suffered their
parent just wasn't home and when the
parent was home was exhausted and
stressed and I think that's a a a a cost
to our the the quality of life we have
in New Hampshire that we have to take
into account with these things um I I've
seen it firsthand not in my own family I
didn't work overtime but I saw it in
colleagues in um the stress I I hope I I
asked the committee that keep those
children in mind because they really
they're a collateral damage um of of
this type of a system and please take me
out of the equation because I volunteer
to go my assignment is out in the
community there are people who don't
have an option who are forced to be
there four five times a week and that is
the reality when you have 45% vacancy
over 40 plus when you have 20% vacancy
and you can't go home you don't have
much of an option so so are you saying
that's because there's a difference
between a corrections officer and a
probation officer so we work in the
community so our responsibilities out in
the community we are still the part of
Department of Correction many provision
ofs are volunteered to go help and I
quite frankly speaking I think that's
the reason that that place still is
floting after 45% V
cancy but we still need to be able to
hire more people or retain the people we
have and out of those 45 %
vacancy uh or current 55% employees I
would guarantee you about 15% of them
are eligible to retire because they have
over 20 years so uh it's a field where
people would stay when they are happy I
have seen people working 28 years 29
years but it's also a field where people
say yeah I can't take this anymore so
let's find a common ground where we we
can find a win-win solution where the
people who are done wrong they' have
gotten what they were promised nothing
benefit no no no sweetening paent the
things that they were promised let's
make them whole and we'll move on and I
certainly don't have another time as you
identify that I don't have another time
to come here again next year I've been
coming here every year and I want that
to end I don't want to come again here
let's just be the last year okay all
right thank you other no all right all
right who's next Mr chairman thank for
your time thank you everyone
good afternoon everyone uh thank you for
the opportunity to speak here my name is
Frank Campo and the president of the
Troopers Association uh we have about
300 members uh should have about 362
members um over the past few years and
today and last week and last month and
six months ago I think we've all um you
know talked this through quite a bit and
I don't want to uh rehash a lot of what
you have all heard over the years over
the past few months over the past week
um one thing that um I don't really
think we've had an example of um while
we've had these discussions is sort of a
personal example and what has happened
um to you know one person that I know um
due to these changes that happened in
2011 um you know it's a small story it's
kind of a you know a microcosm of maybe
a a bigger thing but I want to just
bring it to a little bit of a personal
level for you all to to hear and think
about um you know while you uh you know
work through the budget here um there's
a friend of mine who was hired as a
trooper um he came from a family of Law
Enforcement Officers it was in his blood
it was all he ever wanted to do was be a
state trooper and he his dream came true
he got hired I think in 2008 or so and
um you know he was for those first few
years uh one of the best Troopers going
he loved that job I hate to say he loved
it more than me um the changes happened
in 2012 he was I don't know four or five
years into his career smart guy uh one
of the smartest people that I know and
it killed him but he had to come to the
realization that it simply wasn't worth
it to stay in this job anymore it was
all he's ever wanted to do it crushed
his dreams those changes that happened
um in 2012 uh shortly after that a
couple years after I believe he ended up
uh leaving the state police
and you know he still checks in uh with
me to this day um still hates the fact
that he had to leave but um he had to do
what was best for his family and that
unfortunately was to leave and you know
again that's just a a small story um
just just one guy but I can tell you as
I testified on Wednesday in my 20 plus
years or 20 years at the State Police
here I've seen that happen scores of
times we've had talented men and women
leave this place because it just simply
wasn't worth it to stay so I just kind
of want to um you know just bring that
down to maybe a little bit of a personal
level um for you all um and maybe
something a little different that you
may not have heard before and uh that's
really all I have this afternoon unless
there's any questions so in your
friend's case did he move to some other
job that was unrelated to law he did he
moved to another job that was unrelated
to law enforcement yes got you um now
you said you had 300 members is that in
all three tiers is that yes they span
all three tiers yes sir okay and are
there many uh tier A's left or they
there's a handful I'd say
about probably less than 10 okay yep so
there's about 80 to 100 in tier B and
then the rest would be uh tier C gotcha
so the bulk is tier C at this point yes
sir yes great other
questions no I'm not seeing any hands
thank you very much thank you very much
anybody else would like to talk yes come
back yeah
good afternoon again uh I'm John selli
uh Sergeant with nationville Police
Department I'm here representing the New
Hampshire Police Association uh I just
want to come back up to clarify things a
couple things I don't think uh
representative uh leechman got his
answer as far as the terc portion I
don't think it was clear in the
importance of why we're here for the
tier B folks um as it currently sits
there was a recent article uh from do
police and I mentioned it in my
testimony the other day with each tier B
member that leaves prematurely or as
soon as they can without staying uh and
retaining those folks we're creating
another vacancy each vacancy takes
approximately 12 months to fill between
testing background police academy and
then uh training field training for
those officers because we don't want to
just throw them out there uh and that
cost the the city of and I I'll speak to
NASA and and their article said about
100,000 Nash was about1 to $120,000 for
that cost and then you compound that
with you have to fill those vacancies
with overtime so it's probably more like
a a
$200,000 cost uh to the cities and towns
and when you start getting into a single
Department losing you know four and five
folks a year on this um you're creating
that burnout for those folks that need
to be forced uh you're creating uh a
problem with the vacancies in the
communities but it's very important to
identify the reason to keep these tier B
folks is so we do have that time to
potentially correct the ti sea folks or
figure out a way to recruit more people
um you know and and as Brian said
earlier I mean will somebody be back
here for TRC I'm sure at some point they
probably will be um but in the meantime
we need to stop that bleeding we need to
stop the water going through the dam and
that's by retaining the folks that we
have and then work on those other folks
and a lot of them uh at least I know in
my uh Department have said I knew what I
signed up for I don't love it but I knew
what I signed up for and I'm here for
that and uh they do view this as a
stepping stone uh you know a first phase
to potentially uh creating the entire
overhaul of the system at some point uh
whatever that may look like but they
have until 2037 to to kind of work that
out representative Ms thank you uh Mr
chairman thank you for coming in and
thanks for your service to your
community um about how many uh police
officers across the state are in tier
B when the changes were in uh enacted it
was 1800 well police offices I don't
know the total was
1821 uh I don't have that number as far
as how many are in currently in terb I
know a number of them from my department
alone have retired um but I don't have
an exact number that would be a
retirement board question I apologize I
didn't prepare for
that all right other questions um yeah
I'll I'll make ask you something so um
you talked about trying to recruit
better right um one of the problems that
we have as a state is just a lack of
young people right we we see in our
schools uh a a declining population over
time right it's just a matter of there
aren't as many
births and and uh so 10 years ago I
think or or 12 there was maybe um
220,000 public school kids and now
there's 160,000 that kind of thing right
and so um and that's where we draw from
for these kind of jobs right it's people
out of high school and
so there may just not be the
availability right of of more people
regardless of what we pay them uh to to
take these jobs what do you think agreed
um there's certainly a shortage of work
staff across every entity uh I can I
know that nashaa
is either the highest or one of the top
two or three highest paid in the state
and we are not fully staffed uh we have
lost more since 2015 than we've been
able to recruit and we've recruited 10
12 a year every single year and that
that's a lot for law enforcement
especially a local agency um but you
just we we were unable to keep up with
it uh so again I mean I think that just
solidifies our point that we need to
retain what we have while we try to
figure out that problem and get more
people uh and back to my testimony the
other day uh you're right we we only
have we have 107 out of 164 police
officers are from
Massachusetts uh so yeah it's difficult
to I think we have 45 from uh New
Hampshire and then the rest are from out
of state we have some from Arizona
Florida Colorado that have moved this
way and they've sought out National
Police Department to work which is great
um but yeah we don't have the high New
Hampshire contingency coming out and for
for this job so we need to retain what
we have before we run into a crisis like
uh Probation and Parole and Corrections
U imagine if our law enforcement on the
street was down 45% 50%
what that would look like yeah represent
R thank you um thank you Sergeant for
taking my question you mentioned the
number of people from Massachusetts that
have come to work in the NASA police
department how would you say um using
Nash as an example how competitive are
we are with other states I mean if we
are not getting
homegrown uh law enforcement officers
from New Hampshire I mean we can recruit
young people to come in and move to New
Hampshire take these jobs and raise
their families
whatever so how I mean can you comment
on that about as far as our
competitiveness with neighboring states
speaking to myself I left Massachusetts
law enforcement 13 years because the
wages were competitive and the
retirement was better uh today I look
back and I say I could have retired in
two years from now with 80% of my pay in
in healthcare um so today we're not as
competitive our salaries are certainly
close to you know Massachusetts our cost
of living in New Hampshire has gone up
significantly because we have so many
people moving up to our state because it
is a great state um but right now we're
not nearly as competitive as we need to
be how about um other aspects of the job
you know safety uh level of crime all
that kind of stuff yeah well I came from
a a police department in sagus uh of 6
to a police department of when I got
hired I think we were
170 um we're a far safer State we do a
much better job training uh I do think
that Nashua and I'm going to be biased I
think we're the best agency you know
around for sure uh we do a great deal of
training we do a really good job of uh
making sure our officers are safe and
we're going home at the end of the night
I uh is comparative to mass mass um we
did not train the same way uh they did
not it wasn't as safety conscious as we
are here in New Hampshire uh I think we
have far less officers going out workers
work related injuries uh things like
that so I think we're a much better
State we hold everyone to the same
standard where Mass there's all over the
state and uh they have different
trainings here uh we're all trained the
same way and I think we do a very good
job okay and but some of that may have
just changed everywhere over time right
people in general might be more safety
con not just than they once were or
something like that it's a well uh I
mean if you look at the stats across
across the country I think ours haven't
our crime hasn't gone up the same way it
has in the Midwest and some other places
in the country so I think we do a very
good job and um even with the declining
numbers we're still still doing that
great all right thank you very much are
there others who want to speak
represented Pearson
good
afternoon for the record Representative
Steve Pearson Rockingham District 13
which encompasses the town of
dairy and I'll uh I'll go through some
preliminaries here real quick I am a
member of tier B I am also an sit on the
I am the legislator that sits on the
emergency first
responder um advisory Council to the
governor and I sat on her transition
team uh I'm going to start with um
something
that has to do with me these guys did a
phenomenal job explaining the
circumstances that exist in their
agencies um so I'm going to briefly
touch on on my agency and then I'm I'm
here really to talk about some nuts and
bolts stuff with the LBA handout um the
city of man I worked for the city of
Manchester fire I've worked for
Manchester fire for 22 years when I
started in Manchester in 2003 we did
approximately 16,000 calls for service
this year we will surpass 30,000 calls
for service
we are doing that this year without
engine one without ladder two and
without ladder five those units were
closed years ago
um due to a number of reasons that
Staffing reduction has led to uh
substantial strains on the
department now you you would bring
forward a employee problem with the
ability to
bring qual qualified people
in this is a this is a legislative
hearing so I'm choosing my my words
carefully um a human in a seat is not
necessarily good for the taxpayer right
you need someone that knows what they're
doing and one of the things that is
concerning is you know one of the things
with the the loss of personnel I have a
sticker inside my helmet that says
firefighting is an ultra hazardous
person profession because it
is and the only way that those hazardous
situations are dealt with are through
training but through
experience when we lose someone that has
substantial
experience the the it's hard to quantify
a loss at that level right because what
encompasses a career in someone is a
plethora of of different things and the
diversity of response the diversity of
situations that we've seen allows
command St staffs and those that in this
case of the fire service command of fire
engine to make
decisions we are at a kind of a critical
point here at least in the city of
Manchester with the way our seniority
Works in that if we do not retain tib
people the knowledge loss is going to be
substantial okay and we are going to be
in situations where we are already
promoting People Too Young that have to
make decisions to which their level of
experience isn't quite
there the mandatory overtime situation
and the situation to which we are hiring
has become so complicated that we had to
buy software to do that never had to do
that when I started they just did it
with a phone we're literally now having
to use software to to be able to fill
excuse me fill the positions and the
requirements that the city of Manchester
demands on on that fire department um we
didn't have have we didn't even have the
term mandatory over time when I started
didn't even exist so that whole thing um
on the very rare occasion that that we
would have a problem they would close a
firehouse today it is here we go
mandatory overtime and there's a process
for that so I tested with 400 people for
nine positions to create a hiring list
today the city of Manchester has zero no
no one and we just filled a FEMA grant
that they struggled to fill for 12
positions because of our understaffing
is so bad we've the federal government
has has given us a grant so um you know
that's not unique to Manchester as the
the gentleman alluded to you know every
agency is having having problems so I
just wanted to bring forward my agency's
experience and my my 22 plus years in
the city of Manchester and how things
changed with that so there that that's
just my personal anecdote now as far as
the nuts and bolts here um I was not
here when the LBA handed out this
document that tries to go through the
changes I think there were some things
that were not questions that were not
answered some things that were not
answered correctly um and upon review of
this there are nine nine typos in this
that on current law that exists in this
document so um you know there was some
questions that were raised and I'm happy
to certainly happy to go through this
with anybody but some of the things that
are in here the changes are were done at
the request of the retirement system
excuse me what what document are you
looking at it's the one that was handed
out it just says group two pension
reform hb2 the sideways one all right I
think we have to look for yeah all right
give us a moment we will
go find
that this one
the T the typos are a let's go at Page
by Page we can go Page by Page you're
the chair
absolutely this this
one I got it in here
so you don't have it it should have been
on the table in front not that one no no
it's it's the one that
went oh all
right I I got I U picked this up in here
it was
okay so what's what's wrong with this
one this one has has uh house buillt two
2023 house bu two
2025 House Bill 4
727 not sure about that one
yeah um can do that I mean run next door
our I mean this is today's date right so
um why don't we give you this one that
we all have all
right go go up that
one this is this
is the only reason this other one works
so good is because it shows you what's
being crossed out I mean it's the
typical way that we do we do legislation
here
so I mean I
can yeah y this is this is I'm not sure
that's our document I'm trying to find
it but I I don't yeah no that came right
out of this room this is from here from
last week so what page of
hb2 like
28 oh man okay I that I I don't have a
cross reference
all right I mean I'm willing to there's
nothing on here all right let's we'll
we'll break until uh for five minutes
and Jack will make copies of what
there's nothing on here that is uh I
don't think that
it's oh yeah which is fine it just
highlights we'll come back at at Theos
225 but we we can't stay forever yeah
there's
e
e e
this is this is the
problem
this
e e
all right let's get started again thank
you representative well thank you sir
and Mr chair and so one of the things
that that happened in order
to make changes specifically to group
two is there's a lot of sections in RSA
100a that apply to both so you had to
separate them out and that's what most
of this is um in the case of
the
strikeout you wanted to go Page by Page
um let's start on page one
sure current law so vested right that is
a request of the
courts because the RSA 100a does not
contain a definition of the word
vested which makes us the only plan that
I could find without a definition of the
word vested we have operated under a
Pres resumption of 10
years and that's based on a on a
disability benefit but but in
definitions it just didn't didn't
exist so that that's the purpose of
that the the 10 years of service
remained as it is in current law right
now so there's the budget implication is
zero it's no change
um the rest of page one really applies
to page two because it's cut when it
separated out when there are certain
phrases that existed in the hole that
don't apply to group one or don't apply
to group two so as you saw in my
handwriting red you know renumber to two
and three because the section two is
redundant that was removed at the
request of Mr Carlin because it appears
somewhere else in law it doesn't take
that away it just it's listed twice so
he's like it doesn't need to be in here
twice that was just language cleanup um
and then the compensation for extra and
special Duty that doesn't exist in group
one so that's why it struck there
because it's it applies to group two
only um right so this is basically
separating out there's a lot of mixture
between one and two and so on and this
is making a cleaner correct here's a one
here's a 2 a here's a
2B and when this was done this this was
done in Hill 436 for the most part and
it was run through the the retirement
system to make one to make sure it was
correct obviously right and two because
there were nuances in language that
obviously they understand far better
than I do right so so again on page
three the removal of permanent firemen
and permanent policemen doesn't apply to
group one they're not in group
one uh on page four the reason it's and
is because it had commas and when you
only have two you can't you need the
word and that's right that's right and
it's the same thing with the paragraph
below when you you had three references
you drop to two you need the word and
right and that holds true for page
five the word and Mr chairman I think
while we're on the record it's important
to point out this is not an LBA document
uh we don't know where I we don't know
where it came from we have never seen
this document nor have we handed it out
I think maybe a lobbyist might have left
it there one day but this is the first
time this is a a substantial amount of
work whoever did it and they they might
I we have never seen that before and we
have never handed it out to the
members I got it in
here okay it it may have just for the
just for the record it's not all right
so maybe uh Carol left it here yeah
maybe that's what happened I will show
it to her and we it may have come from
the chair of Edna all right but that's
possible sure we'll just make it clear
on this video that we are looking at at
a document that we are unable to
possibly make public because we don't
know where it came from so well I can
tell you that having gone through it
other than the typos that we'll talk
about at the end with the transcription
everything's accurate um so like on page
so getting into page
seven where we start talking about some
of some of the dates and the movement of
time um so what about page five there's
a lot of new stuff here so so P when
well when you separate group one you
have to make a par for group two I see
you have no choice right it doesn't
exist so the entire paragraph becomes
technically new language because it
didn't exist but it's the same it is so
it is the same with the
differentiations right because group one
and group two are now separated out go
okay and it it just runs through Page
Six
okay so the way that this the way that
this works is this whole thing works is
you can't well you could in theory have
this done in one shot but of course the
price tag is atrocious so this is a this
does two things it transitions this over
time to so it's not a a huge hit at once
but it also contains a
concession over
time in that concession is that the
length of
service that was added to those careers
remains that is a concession that was
made
by the stakeholders in order for this to
work they are the in the changes that
occurred in 2011 that forced them to
work a longer career are still in
there okay so that's when you're going
to you're starting to see the dates the
January 1 of 12 dates are starting to
get in the
gray mhm that's why that's why those are
that has to do with the movement of time
year to year now I will say at the
bottom of seven in number two where it
says and who have not attained vested
status prior to January 1 of 12 if you
were hired in Janu July 1 of 11 there is
no scenario in the world that gets you
vested in six months so that so that
language is a cleanup it was a request
of of the retirement system it just
didn't it just didn't need to be there
so um
again separate page eight is a
separation of one and two so that's why
paragraphs A and B are the
same but it differentiates between the
two and then you get down to a paragraph
D1 which is group two and again the
transitioning of the
dates is is all that is that's why it's
the only thing highlighted is the date
itself
um unfortunately on page nine and again
we we've made it abundantly clear that
this document did not come from the
LBA um for some reason the someone
transcribed 2012 to
2021 easy thing to do we've all done it
that's so I just don't what I don't want
is
confusion for anyone that had this to
think that this is affecting 2021 in
backwards that that is not the case in
any way it's just merely a
typo and then unfortunately you're
saying the actual document doesn't have
that it does not no it does not have the
typo so unfortunately that typo carries
through
um several
places now we'll move to page 13 and
just for the new folks to explain why
the chart on page 13 became
larger the original
chart clumped groups together in 2year
chunks with the exception of the fir the
the last one which was a four-year chunk
all that the expansion of the chart at
the bottom did was just put it Year bye
it did not change conditions age
multiplier nothing all it did was it
separated it from two-year blocks into
oneyear blocks so that as this bill
Works through annually you can make an
ual change if we had not done that it
would have created disparity depending
on when you were hired where some people
would had to work two years longer and
others maybe six months that isn't
really fair so by separating it out it
left it more more Equitable as it went
through that's all it did but the
conditions itself there is no there is
absolutely zero change in
that um
let's six years
what does it
mean it look toward the top at least six
years but 22 age 47 right so what
happened is in
2011 in 2011 what h a couple things
happened when you looked at the changes
that were made to group two and you took
an individual change by itself a lot of
them seem kind of minor innocuous right
but the problem was is they had a
cumulative effect whereas okay I was
subject to this change but that number
is now subject to this event which was
changed which is now subject to a third
event which was changed and when you
looked at it holistically which was not
done you realize and this is why Senator
Bradley made the statement on the floor
of the Senate recorded on the floor of
the Senate that this we went way too far
because they didn't look at it cumula
they were just looking at in individual
chunks so let me start with that now as
far as your question Mr
chairman repeat it please so if you look
at this highlighted stuff toward the top
of the page on 13 on page 13 yep as
number one less than four years 24 age
49 2.1% so the conditions that existed
when these people were hired is they had
to do 20 years of service and be 45
years old okay so what this does is it
they're really columns here they're
columns yeah unfortunately that didn't
that doesn't translate well in the so so
24 is years of service minimum years of
service correct right okay minimum years
age is their minimum age and then they
get 2.1% correct for that gotcha yep
those those conditions here like I said
when the chart expanded have not changed
mhm the other thing is that the and that
that is a concession that was was agreed
upon really right I I want you guys to
understand that the the folks behind me
the group two Coalition did not walk
into a room and slam their fist on a
table that that didn't happen they have
an incentive as well as we do as a
legislature to make the pension system
work
so that's what ultimately happened is
they said okay we understand that the
most expensive element to a change in
the pension system is a reduction in
length of service because the longer you
work in a system the better it actually
is for the system
financially
so that is a concession that they agreed
upon and it's not minor when you're
asking someone to work longer at a
minimum you are in essence
it's you're you are forcing their
employment
so I I that's
that's really not a minor ask they that
was a
serious concession on the on the group
two folks part but that so just so we
understand the other thing is that this
chart and it's been I've had six or
eight people now at say well the title
of the chart isn't highlighted it
doesn't change the date did you miss
something no the reason the title of the
chart still has the 2011 date is because
if you choose to leave early you suffer
a penalty for doing so you do not get
the benefit of this proposed change if
you don't agree to the deal that's in
front of you so if you leave early you
are going to then have to fall under the
prior
conditions that is a retention element
gotcha to say what's the less than four
years part that's four years of service
so so less than four years of service
would mean you were hired in
200 N or 10 or 11
that was that was the time of service
that you had in group two as of July 1
of 2011 oh okay yeah so this is as of
gotcha so July 1 of 2011 is the is the
large Line in the
[Music]
Sand for so F folks that were hired
after that date are tier C folks I
understand yep yes represent so is that
a typo then when it says credible
service on minimum years minimum annuity
January 1 2012 so that no oh okay it is
not a typo okay so you're so
2011 that's kind of the cutof date so
unfortunately when this was
written it's almost I'm trying to think
of some jargon it's almost like the word
Cruiser and cop car mean the same thing
right right they do except that when you
do that in law saying you are hired July
111 or you were vested as
of that's that that's both ways of
coming to a date in using two different
methods okay so it makes unfortunately
this complicated to read because it's
interchanging two terms now when we get
to the end of this you'll see that that
has been completely cleaned up at the
end but that's not going to occur until
2034 okay all right let's let's let's
move on I think I understand this so
again the the typo parts are listed the
reason on 14 it says not in fiscal note
and I crossed off the word not there was
a question that was that came before
Edna in reference to a fiscal note that
was assigned to House Bill 727 that bill
has a typo in it and we weren't sure if
the fiscal note reflected a typo or if
it reflected actual current law we have
since consulted with Jan who is the
director of the retirement system and
she assured me that they caught that
typo and that the fiscal note was done
with current law not the typo in 727 so
that was just a note that's why that
note is there for me frankly but that's
that's why it's there all 2021 should
be2 correct and and as you right as you
get through that into 16 it like I said
they were just those are just the typos
now where
the Roman numeral meets the column here
is on page
16 this is how
this works as far as transitioning folks
let me ask about 15 sure uh effective
date
2034 correct so what's that so what that
does is this here is
where we are in let me make make sure I
get this
right we are now starting to get into
the situation where the vested as and
the hiring date are being cleaned up to
just
become one word in the removal of the
reference of 100 A5 2D which is that
chart that had the age in length the
service you just referenced that chart
expires it goes away so if there's any
references in in statute to a chart
can't they can't be there because the
chart no longer exists so it just
removes our reference to a chart that
that doesn't exist anymore I see okay go
ahead this is with the the program
changes year to year correct right see
okay yep so at the like I said at the
end it when the chart goes away any
reference to that and you'll you'll see
that on 16 17 and 18 the and that runs
you through the
it condenses the changes into the
paragraphs annually is just how that I
personally I don't like it it was the
insistence of OSS to write it this
way HB 436 I thought wrote it in a way
that was a little bit easier to
understand but that was I lost that
fight with with ol so new we have a new
drafting attorney that handles the
pension stuff straka retired and uh he
has his own style
so at the at the
end where you get the 2034 references
that all of the January 1 2034
references are done to eliminate the
double speak as to establishing a date
and just simply puts it at July 1 of 11
it's a hard Line in the Sand and it
makes it easy for a lay person to read
and understand
okay prior to the these changes in 2011
people filled out their request for a
pension on a
postcard now they have to go in and make
an appointment they get a preliminary
number they have to see my fine friend
back here who is both a numbers
scruncher and an attorney they will give
you a
guess it's a guess as to what you're
getting you will receive the start of
your pension with a reduced number and
when they finally figure it out they'll
adjust it retroactive ly paywise and you
will get your final
number that used to be an appointment
that took 20 minutes and
it's in a perfect world we would go back
to something far more
simpler um
but this this these changes here that
are proposed in House Bill 2 do simplify
things
eventually but it's just going to take
some time represent Ms thank you Mr
chair and thank you for coming in so I
just I want to make sure I'm clear so
with with the changes that you've
highlighted it this this reflects what
the governor's ask is this is out of
house bill to this is the governor's ask
okay okay yep thank you if if I wrote
this it would if I was submitting this
it would look a little different but um
this is this
is you know she she wants what she wants
and I was happy to oblige in her request
of me um and I did what she
asked
okay
so so on
um page four of our main document that
we got today right this
one we're actually seeing the cost of
these
things
um so House Bill 2 has
introduced
2025 237 million present cost this is if
we had that much today that's what it
would cost you know paying it out over
10 years
different um but House Bill 2
2023 two years
ago is Le half them so
um that's
interesting there there is an element Mr
chair that that is could be better
explained by the retirement system but
I've I've heard his explanation a dozen
times so I'll give it a shot here the
retirement system invests money and
money has a time element to it when you
make an investment so when this when the
the first proposal to make a change in
this occurred in 2 th my first term
which was four terms ago that had a a
fiscal cost of $136 million for a
complete in total one-time
shot as time has progressed and every
delay that has occurred it has added a
roughly between 25 and $28 million a
year so the progression of time is an
enemy to to solving the problem because
they are not
receiving the income to invest
the other thing that changes is the is
the Corpus of the folks has been reduced
we're losing people that were in this
original group of 1800 that is now in
the 1600s so there that makes an
adjustment as well gotcha Mr chair yes
represent um to you know to your to your
point I mean if I'm reading this chart
correctly it looks like the significant
difference between
hb2 two years ago and hb2 now looks like
it has to do with the treatment of uh
extra what esdp extra service duty
pay I mean it it you know if you look at
the the comments that the differen is it
says the cost difference between HB 727
is which is essentially the same as hb2
of two years ago is largely attributable
to hb2 of this year not containing the
change in maximum benefit and
eliminating the seven-year rule for
esdp can you talk about talk to that CU
that's that looks like that's
160 million all right before you go
representative Pearson representative
Sweeny would like to say just I would
just say it looks like underneath hb2 as
introduced there's hb2 2025 without the
omission of esdp so they already
calculated that for us between 237 237
million and 194 million
25.6 a year
contrib is unavailable is this what they
were telling us was probably a typo in
the governor's
language I think retirement's here if
they want yeah okay come on I I I guess
the you know if I could I mean if you're
asking him intent on the governor's
language
he I'm not I was just I've been cross
referencing the document that representa
Pearson brought and yes it's there's
definitely some issues I don't even
think we should and I not I know you did
a lot of work and because it's not our
document it's not retirement's document
and it makes things even more confusing
when you try to cross reference what's
in the document that you know Steve
picked up over there a week or so ago
but retirement is here I hopefully I can
speak their
numers I agree okay and it's getting
late on a Friday
yeah thanks for
coming again I'm Mark Kavanaugh
Deputy counsel and compliance
officer um Marty's replacement was here
but he had to leave oh we have one
another commitment he started on Monday
great and we'll be working together he
and I the rest of this session and and
what's his name his name is
Rick faio you might recognize the name
as he came to us from B he was a
lobbyist at Bia great business industry
so before I started the chart I just
want to clarify a couple of things that
representative Pearson mentioned okay
there is a definition of vested in our
statute it's not in the definition
statute but it's an RSA
10810 and that says that if a member has
10 years of service at the time they
terminate work but aren't old enough to
retire they can collect a benefit when
they get old enough and that's called a
vested deferred benefit that's where the
10 years comes from gotcha we don't need
a separate definition I understand okay
second um when he I don't know if this
clarifies but um the way these options
work is that successively moving the
vested by date year by year by year
until
2034 is what encompasses all the current
tib members and that's why that chart
goes away because there will everyone
will have already been fixed uh and last
let me ask just a detail about that
suppose someone stopped working for 5
years and then came back is that an
issue or is that well I it's a footnote
in my chart and oh okay and I can speak
to that it's an ambiguity okay but
probably doesn't happen that often right
so don't know but this might incentivize
people yeah
um and
lastly um he said you fill out an
estimate card and and that's how you get
counseled anyone can have an appointment
but in this day and age people go on the
internet just want a file or they want
an estimate card and send it in but
anyone can come in as many times as they
want and spend an hour or two with one
of our benefit Specialists and go over
everything we didn't change our rules
behavior of our membership
changed okay enough on that um so the
purpose of this uh document is to to
compare the provisions
between hb2
2023 hb2 727 from earlier this year in
hb2
2025 many of them the same but there
were two or three significant
differences that account for the
variations in cost on the last page so
earnable compensation those changes are
the same in all three bills
calculation period in from five to three
years and eliminating the compensation
over base limitation same in all three
bills
okay AFC changes to the
es DP
limitations are in
hb2 and HB
727 they that the limitation which
commonly applies to tier a but will
apply to the tier BS who hit their
vested VI dat that essentially makes
them tier a in almost all regards
um that definition is taken out of hb2
it was it it's something in current
law and it's remained in hb2 in 2023 and
in HB
727 uh but it was taken out of
hb2 and therefore for TI would no longer
be subject to the limitation that in
their High three years their average
esdp cannot exceed their High seven
years uh since
2012 so it's like the coob rule by
comparing you know but it's it it and
it's been in the law for quite some time
and it's um effective so you're you're
you're saying that hb2
2025 has a change for tier a uh no no
hb2 2023 and hb2
2025 kept the law as it currently is
which has this limit on how much special
Duty you can have in your high three
years okay hb2 2025 took that out yes
okay so that increases the cost because
that limitation is going away yes all
right but that's a change not just for
tier B but also for tier a yes uh no uh
uh yes so tier tier a led the limitation
too yes yeah okay and it's probably and
we think that's a mistake because we
don't think the intention was to change
tier I don't know about the the intent I
was deducing the way the drafting that
could have been a mistake maybe right
but you'd have to talk to Steve and the
governor about whether it was
intentional or not understand okay um so
the service retirement benefit
calculation
hb2
um said that we would
increase um I'm sorry that it's
2.5% once someone gets to the arested by
date and for anyone who retires before
it's 2.4 to 2.1 to 2.4 under the chart
that currently
applies hb7 27 is a little bit different
because in the interim we passed HB 1647
that gave 2 and a half% for over 15
years and so this is 2.1 to 2.4 for the
first 15 years in in in in in 2.5 after
for people who retire before their
vested date for the those who who who
continue in service until their vested
date get the increased benefits the same
as under HB 2 and 2023
and hb2 2025 is the same as HB 727 so
there was no change in the governor's
bill from 727 earlier this year okay uh
moving on
to uh page three
um in the left column you see what the
current rules are about maximum
benefit what and it says you know people
who commend service prior to 7109
and these
changes
um have the
effect because they changed that cutoff
date from
7019 to 7101 in hb2 2023 727 used
1199 um instead of
7101 the difference is from current law
is that now applies the maximum benefit
to a group of people who it didn't apply
to before and that's a cost
savings the governor's bill doesn't
include that so by comparison the
governor's bill has maintains current
law and so by comparison to the other
two bills that's why that's the other
factor that that makes it cost
more um now to uh if I'll take any
questions on the substance before we go
to the cost if anyone has any questions
yeah let's get to page four but it may
we may end up going backwards
okay
so hb2
2023 so what we ask the actuary to do is
um give us a
number that would be have a neutral
effect on the
UA okay so these cost estimates are that
part of it
only it does not include the impact on
contribution rates going forward because
of the nature of that calculation and
the unpredictability of wage growth and
other Actuarial factors that is not
conducive to bringing it back to a
present value because of the uncertainty
of the facts whereas dollars you predict
the dollars and that they're easy to
bring down so th that's a little
different um and that's why these we
don't include any comparative impact on
the uh com uh member employer rates
um so what
the what the actuary did is he looked at
HB
2023 and said that uh there wasn't a
real material difference in in the um
the provisions and therefore he valued
it the same as hb2 727 for which we did
a full valuation earlier this year so uh
and that's just go to the point I should
have set up front is we can give you a
hard exact number if there's a full
valuation the only one we've done it for
is 727 hb2 is almost done for 2025 and
hb2 for 2023 because it was so similar
to 727 he said I'm going to use the 727
number and I'm going to figure out that
it's $10,300 to pay for it without
having increase or decrease in the UA
because as you recall the bills proposed
27.5 million which would decreased the
UA by 98.2 million
so we're just trying to find a neutal
cost that
um and that's what that number is so
when you go to hb2
2025 you go why is that 237
400 yes that's the cost of the impact of
removing the special Duty
provision and not changing the maximum
benefit so by comparison to the other
statutes that's why that difference is
so significant show us the maximum
benefit let's go back yeah thank you
that's page three page
three
so what this means is
again because 2023 and hb7
both changed or proposed to change the
cfff date for when the maximum benefit
applies by moving it back in
time 7101 in one case 11 199 it's now
subjecting
members to the maximum benefit who were
not are not subject to it under current
law and that includes group one as well
as group two so that is a big element of
the cost differential that's sping no no
that's not spiking I don't I don't use
the word spiking just I just was
repeating you it's a maximum benefit at
the end of your care not at the end of
your it's a maximum benefit based on in
this case current law for people hired
prior to
7109 it's 100% of their highest year of
compensation for people hired on or
after 7109 it's 8 5% of average final
compensation or
$120,000 are we changing the period of
which we average from no from five years
to three years all this is doing is
saying what at what date does it did a
member have to be hired in order
to be subject to the maximum benefit and
by moving that date from 09 to 01 you've
got got eight more years of people who
are going to be subject to the benefit
who aren't currently and that's why
there's a cost savings the way I read it
in in hb2 language it instead of going
back average your highest three or
average five years it said your your
last year couldn't be more than the year
before that which just gets it down to
two years of spiking in
five I don't recall that in any versions
of these so statutes proposals let me
restate what you just said and see if
you agree okay okay um um So
currently current law says that your
final pension cannot be greater than um
for most people okay uh your highest
year of
earnings right um for most people no for
people hired before
719 so that's people who that's 16 years
ago so anyone who started work in the
last 16 years is subject to the second
maximum which is
85% and it's 85% of AFC not highest year
of earnable comp so that's that's a
limitation built into the that as well
okay because you're averaging over five
years not Tak just the highest year and
it's
$112,000 was the a dollar amount
whichever W1 125,000 uh well law is 120
the proposals would have increased it to
125 gotcha so so the numbers are the
same in each of these options it's just
the change in the cutof date now
subjects more people to the maximum
benefit Who currently are not subject to
it and as compared to the governor's
bill which didn't make those
changes these bills cost less oh because
of the savings so you that
today these maximums aren't in no
they're in but they just apply to fewer
people okay and they stay in under the
hb2 for this year correct no no I mean
yes yes so the the the column the where
it says you know on on page three the
the column all the way on the left
maximum benefit provision that is that
is what is in hb2 2025 right it's not in
either of the other two it's in but with
different cut off different provisions
and so for the purposes of trying to
compare the three
bills you have to take that into account
that these Savings in hp2 AR the result
of any deliberate uh changes in the law
it's just maintaining the current
law so these so current
law has
these has or doesn't doesn't have
these cut off oh it has a different cut
off it has a different maximum has a ma
has the same maximum in terms of 100%
for one group 85 or 120 for another
group it's just that the group is bigger
under 2023 in HB 727 because it was
moving the hired by date to a back in
time so all those people hired between
the two dates are now s to a maximum so
what those bills were doing was giving
the whole group group bigger
multipliers but but limiting the top end
is that is that applying the limit on
the top end to more people to more
people and and what the intent of that
was I'm not
sure okay all right okay but as compared
to hb2
2025 the other two options are cheaper
because hb2 doesn't provide for the
change and maintains current law it
maintains the size of that group yes but
it's also giving them the bigger
multipliers and the other
improvements right so that's why it's
more more expensive I see yes and so
those are the factors that account for
the differences in the cost primarily
there were other Actuarial factors that
that uh so hb2 2023 and HP 20 727
2025 were sort of giving on one side but
taking away on another
side yeah apparently yes I can't speak
to what the intent was again but yes
effectively this side is limiting a
little and that side is being a little
more generous right and where you
limiting applies to group one also oh
okay yeah so does does anything in hb2
2025 apply to group one or no no no no
because that's that's the only common
Pro provision at stake here um that uh
is is this um maximum benefit and the
changes to the earnable comp but the
changes to the earnable comp don't apply
to okay TR don't apply well I'm sorry
I'm not explaining that correctly
um the changes to earnable comp are
bifurcated just as a definition between
now going to be B at
between group one and group
two the maximum benefit doesn't make a
distinction between them okay applies to
everyone just a moment so hb2
2023 made group one
lesser without any improvements to group
one because it added this limitation no
it makes it no no it changed the
limitation so it costs
more in other words
you've got that same the group of people
subject to the maximum is also increased
for group one but not in
2023 yes 20
2023 2023 and and and hb7 27 are the
same right so for those two
bills group one got hurt is that what
you're saying no um group more people
will be subject to the maximum more
people will be subject to the maximum
yeah and there was no other Improvement
for group one in those bills no right
okay so group one got
hurt hurts the subjective term I'm not
going to use a lesser benefit or as a
group right as a group they got less
benefits they got less benefits thank
you but I would
say yes it's far less common for group
ones to hit the maximum benefit because
they have the lower multiplier yes yes
well this is this is what I'm reading
meting that you know I I thought we went
to 5 years averaging yes this says um
compensation of extra and special Duty
as reported by the employer shall be
included but limited during the highest
three years of credible Service as
provided in paragraph 18 however
earnable compensation in the final 12
months of credible Services prior to
termination of employment shall be
limited to 1 and 1/ half times the
higher of the earnable compensation in
the 12 month period preceding the final
12 months of the highest compensation is
determined for the purpose of
calculating average final compensation
but excluding the final 12 months any
compensation received in the final 12
months of employment in excess of such
limit shall not be subject to member or
employment or employer contribution so
it's still allowing for extra extra yes
in your last two years yes instead of
your last three so the the instead of of
five yeah yeah so it's it's it's going
to skew it tremendously two separate R
rules okay that that 150% R we refer to
it's been around for years it's
completely different it just says if in
your final year it's a kind of a
companion to some of the other
Provisions that were designed to limit
how much we count at the end of a career
but it's it's a different rule it's been
around for longer and it just says that
if in your final
year your earnable compensation is more
than 150% of what it was in your
penultimate year we're going to only
count what you got in your penultimate
year okay so that's but you're also
subject to the other rules that other
than like the cob rule that
limits how much Co in your high five
against how much C you had on average in
your whole career so they're companion
Provisions but they operate totally
differently and so one does not mean the
other doesn't exist well it's still
allows you to build it up or spike it as
my in my term well you could in the
penultimate year you you could increase
it all right just a moment but that's
going to be in your that's going to be
in your high three average and it's
currently subject to the compensation
over base rule yes yes okay um I'm
sensing that we're we're at the end of
our ability to to to focus on this but I
will let representative MS ask the last
last question I just wanted to ask about
this you know the seven-year um
seven-year rule so it looks like if I'm
understanding this correctly this the
seven-year rule on extra special duty
pay was
implemented in
2011 um previous to that there was no
such rule it looks like there's some
confusion as to whether the governor has
eliminated that rule or left that rule
in place um and it and based on your I
guess that that' be my first question is
that is that your I mean you've given us
two cost estimates one with the
seven-year Rule and one without so I'm
assuming there's some confusion there so
well I just wanted to point out because
I wasn't sure if if was intentional okay
because this provision was in one part
of the the current law that addresses
group one yeah uh I I
mean it was taken out of one section of
Law and it was it and it could have been
mistakenly or intentionally not included
in the new definition that applies
representative Pearson is shaking his
head saying that it was intentional um
yeah and so so if that's the case then
the
2374 100 the 237 million dollar number
is the number that is reflective of
what's in the
governor's right so taking that out um
is the difference between 2374 and 19
1946 so it's $43 million to take it
out thank you all right we will be back
here on uh Monday at 10: is that right
was how much work are you doing over the
weekend a lot okay so you might answer
an email or
two all right good well I will be doing
a lot as well all right thank you very
much
everyone
[Laughter]
okay fine that just clarifies
[Music]
for
nothing
e
e for